When you're with Amex Platinum, you get access to exclusive dining experiences and an annual travel credit. So the best tapas in town might be in a new town altogether. That's the powerful backing of Amex. Terms and conditions apply. Learn more at Amex.ca. where's your playlist taking you down the highway to the mountains or just into daydream mode while you're stuck in traffic with over 4,000 hotels worldwide best western is there to help you make the
当您使用美国运通白金卡时，您将获得独家餐饮体验和年度旅行积分。所以城里最好的塔帕斯餐厅可能在另一个全新的城市。这就是美国运通强大的后盾。适用条款和条件。详情请访问 Amex.ca。您的播放列表会带您去哪里？是去高速公路，去山上，还是在堵车时进入白日梦模式？在全球拥有超过 4,000 家酒店，最佳西方酒店随时为您服务，帮助您充分利用您的假期，无论您身在何处，因为除了很棒的播放列表，唯一更好的就是一次很棒的旅行。生活就是一场旅行，在最佳西方酒店尽情享受吧，并访问 bestwestern.com 节省费用。欢迎来到《商学院》的第二杯。这一集进入了戴夫·罗杰斯 (Dave Rogers) 的十大超级粉丝剧集名单。所以，如果您喜欢原版，一定要去 Peacock 上看看。嗯，这是我最喜欢的剧集之一。我知道我们经常这么说，但我确实非常喜欢这一集。
most of your getaway wherever that is because the only thing better than a great playlist is a great trip life's the trip make the most of it at best western and save at bestwestern.com. Welcome to the second drink of business school. This episode made Dave Rogers' top 10 superfan episode list. So if you loved the original, you're going to have to check it out on Peacock. Well, this is one of my favorite episodes. I know we say that a lot, but I do truly love this episode.
您确实喜欢。我也一样。而且，如果我可以说的话，我们对它的解析非常棒。我们有编剧布伦特·福斯特 (Brent Forster) 分享他创作和拍摄《商学院》的回忆。我们还听到了凯特·弗兰纳里 (Kate Flannery) 的讲述，她为我们揭秘了德怀特、梅雷迪思和蝙蝠的那场戏。太棒了。这一集还有我在整个系列中最喜欢的德怀特台词之一。我知道是哪一句。是关于白痴的那句。是的，当我为人们的生日和毕业制作视频时，我总是引用他的话。我知道我们在解析中谈到了它，但我们没有播放它。我想听听。好的。我曾经对你说过的最鼓舞人心的话是什么？别当个白痴。它改变了我的人生。每当我准备做某事时，我都会想，白痴会那样做吗？如果他们会，我就不做那件事。我太喜欢它了。我的意思是，这真的是非常非常好的生活建议。
You do. I do, too. And our breakdown of it, lady, is so good if I do say so myself. We have writer Brent Forster sharing his memories of writing and filming business school. And we hear from Kate Flannery, who gives us the scoop on that whole Dwight Meredith and the bat scene. Amazing. This episode also has one of my favorite Dwight quotes in the entire series. I know which one it is. It's the idiot one. It is when I make videos for people for their birthdays and graduations. I always quote him. And I know we talked
这很简单，对吧？别当个白痴。我的意思是，女士，我喜欢它。这就是为什么我在给人们的毕业视频中使用这个建议。我想如果你是一个年轻人，你要去上大学。去上大学，你会遇到很多场景，很多选择。是的。我想你会停下来问自己，白痴会做那件事吗？
about it in our breakdown, but we didn't play it. I want to hear it. All right. What's the most inspiring thing I ever said to you? Don't be an idiot. Changed my life. Whenever I'm about to do something, I think, would an idiot do that? And if they would, I do not do that thing. I love it so much. I mean, it's really, really good life advice.
如果答案是肯定的，那就不要做那件事。我觉得这很棒。它确实很简单，直击要点。嗯，我知道你有多喜欢那个采访镜头。我很好奇是否有它的糖果袋备选方案。我没找到任何一个。我想那就是全部了。但是女士，这是我学到的。
It's very simple, right? Don't be an idiot. I mean, lady, I love it. This is why I use this advice in my graduation videos to people. I think if you're a young person, you're going off to college. going off to college, you're going to be presented with a lot of scenarios, a lot of choices. Yeah. And I think you pause and you ask yourself, would an idiot do that thing?
所以迈克尔·斯科特在开场白中有一个采访镜头，那实际上是糖果袋备选方案，而不是实际拍摄草稿中的那个。事情是这样的。记得吗，瑞安说他要带他的老板去上课，因为他的老师说这会自动让你提升一个完整的字母等级。所以瑞安觉得，我不这样做就太蠢了，对吧？然后迈克尔有一个采访镜头，他说老板就像老师，像个酷老师，像他的老师汉德尔先生，他继续说了一会儿。那就是糖果袋备选方案。
And if the answer is yes, then do not do that thing. I think it's great. It really is simple and gets to the point. Well, I know how much you love that talking head. And I was curious if there was a candy bag alt for it. I couldn't find any. I think that was it. But lady, here's what I learned.
但剧本里的那个让我笑喷了，它让我想到了你。什么？你会明白为什么的。这是迈克尔在拍摄草稿中会说的话。最终，我进入商界是为了激励人们。人们说，那些不能做的人就去教书。我可以两者兼顾。我教的是如何去做。因为你喜欢说我们要去做《权力的游戏》，我们要去做这个。你喜欢做。我确实喜欢做。它只是让我想到了你。嗯，就像安吉拉之前提到的，我们有很多关于我们如何拍摄梅雷迪思那场戏的幕后蝙蝠细节。
So Michael Scott has a talking head in the cold open, and that was actually the candy bag alt, not the one in the actual shooting draft. Here's what's going on. Remember, Ryan is saying he's going to be bringing his boss to his class because his teacher said it automatically bumps you up to a full letter grade. So Ryan's like, I'd be stupid not to, right? And then Michael has a talking head where he says that a boss is like a teacher, like a cool teacher, like his teacher, Mr. Handel, and he goes on for a little bit. That was the candy bag alt.
你们很多人想知道我们是否必须对办公室里飞来飞去的真蝙蝠做出反应。我们没有。但你准备好听这个了吗？一些人写信告诉我们，他们有过这样的经历。在他们的办公室里，就像有蝙蝠飞来飞去？是的。凯莉·R 与我们分享。重温这一集让我想起了我深夜在雷雨中独自在办公室工作时，一只蝙蝠开始向我的头俯冲的往事。
But the scripted one lady cracked me up and it made me think of you. What? You'll see why. Here's what Michael would have said in the shooting draft. Ultimately, I went into business to inspire people. They say that those who can't do teach. I can do both. I teach doing. Because you like to say we're going to do Game of Thrones, we're going to do this. You like doing. I do like doing. It just made me think of you. Well, like Angela mentioned before, we have a lot of really great behind-the-scenes bat details on how we film the shots with Meredith.
我当时赶着截止日期，所以我不得不躲避那只蝙蝠一个小时，同时试图继续工作。一个小时？那只蝙蝠在俯冲轰炸？天哪。我会逃走的。凯莉，我会逃走的。凯莉，为什么不离开？她有截止日期。我想也是。既然我们谈到了蝙蝠，还记得吉姆假装被蝙蝠咬伤的恶作剧吗？德怀特说吉姆可能不会变成吸血鬼，只是有吸血鬼基因。是的。嗯，我想分享那个德怀特采访镜头的糖果袋备选方案，因为它真的让我咯咯笑了。德怀特说，吸血鬼蝙蝠倾向于迁徙到斯洛文尼亚，特兰西瓦尼亚，宾夕法尼亚，宾夕法尼亚，可能是斯洛文尼亚学习中心。
And a lot of you wanted to know if we had to react to a real bat flying around the office. And we did not. But are you ready for this? A few folks rode in to tell us that they have had an experience like this. In their office, like a bat flying around? Yes. Kelly R. shared with us. Rewatching this episode gave me flashbacks of the time I was working alone in my office late at night during a thunderstorm and a bat started swooping at my head.
那太搞笑了。所以他们是自找的。他们在宾夕法尼亚州。这注定会发生。哦，我太喜欢了。好吧，听着，在我们走之前，快速提醒一下，《办公室》的前四集将于 9 月 4 日播出，下周我们将在《办公室女士 6.0》中讨论试播集。
I was on a tight deadline so I had to dodge the bat for an hour while I tried to. to continue working. An hour? The bat was like dive bombing? Oh my gosh. I'd be out. Kelly, I'd be out. Kelly, why not leave? She had a deadline. I guess so. And since we are on the subject of bats, remember Jim's prank where he acts like he got bit by the bat? And Dwight says Jim might not turn into a vampire but just have like vampiric jeans. Yes. Well, I wanted to share the candy bag alt for that Dwight talking head because it really made me chuckle. Dwight says, Vampire bats tend to migrate to the Slovenia's, Transylvania, Pennsylvania, Pennsylvania, the Slovenia Learning Centers, probably.
太棒了。重温《办公室》的世界真是太有趣了。啊，我喜欢它。现在是《商学院》的第二杯。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。
That's very funny. So they had it coming. They were in Pennsylvania. This was bound to happen. Oh, I love it. Well, listen, before we go, just a quick reminder that the first four episodes of the paper come out September 4th, and we are going to be talking about the pilot episode next week on Office Lady 6.0.
现在我们正在为您制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们将解析一集《办公室》，并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉您的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。大家好。嘿，我们今天要上商学院了。哦，伙计们，这会非常有趣。
It's so good. It was so fun to revisit the office universe. Ah, I loved it. And now here is the second drink of business school. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends.
我们可能会变得有点疯狂。我对此一无所知。你会知道关于它的一切，因为你和我有一个约会。我迫不及待想和你一起疯狂了。我要把它扔给你，女士。哦，天哪。伙计们，这是第三季第 16 集，由布伦特编写，乔斯·韦登执导。
And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hello, everyone. Hey, we are going to business school today. Oh, you guys, it's going to be so fun.
我要给你一个总结。做吧。我今天写总结写得很简洁。哦，它太简洁了，以至于你不得不提出来。我确实提了。嘿，伙计们，准备好迎接简洁的总结吧。哦，快速说五遍。瑞安带迈克尔去他的商学院做客座演讲。
We might get our frizz on. I wouldn't know anything about that. You're going to know everything about it because you and I have a fronthing date. I can't wait to fronf with you. I'm going to chunk it at you, lady. Oh, boy. Guys, this is season three, episode 16, written by Brent, and directed by Joss Whedon.
一只蝙蝠在办公室里造成了混乱。吉姆假装变成德古拉来恶作剧德怀特。帕姆在艺术展上展示她的艺术作品。听起来很简单，对吧？四个简单的句子，但它一点也不简单。它很简单，但内容丰富。我有一点要补充。布伦特在 DVD 评论中说，他从墙上拿了两张卡片。
I'm going to hit you with a summary. Do it. I wrote my summary really succinct today. Oh, it's so succinct that you had to call it out. I did. Hey, guys, get ready for some succinct summary. Ooh, say that five times fast. Ryan brings Michael to be a guest speaker at his business school.
你知道，我们谈过作家们在墙上有所有这些卡片。是的。他只是拿了两张 3x5 的卡片。一张写着商学院，另一张写着办公室里的蝙蝠。嗯，看看那个。一张简洁的笔记卡，正好配上我简洁的总结。我想商学院是格雷格的主意。他一直知道在未来的某个时候，他想去瑞安的商学院。
A bat causes mayhem at the office. Jim pretends to be turning into Dracula to prank Dwight. Pam shows her art at an art exhibition. It sounds so simple, right? Four simple sentences, and yet it is not simple at all. It's simple, but there's so much. I have one little thing to add. Brent says in the DVD commentary, he was handed two cards off the wall.
我想那张卡片在墙上已经挂了一段时间了。嗯，安吉拉，说到蝙蝠的故事线，第一个快速事实，乔斯·韦登执导了这一集。所以乔斯因创作了由莎拉·米歇尔·盖拉主演的系列剧《吸血鬼猎人巴菲》而闻名。这是 WB 电视网的一部大热剧，当时由苏珊·丹尼尔斯管理。苏珊的丈夫是格雷格·丹尼尔斯。这就是乔斯如何获得执导该剧一集的机会。但我猜他被分配到有蝙蝠和吸血鬼故事线的那一集纯属巧合。我记得他说，拜托，伙计们，你们给了我蝙蝠吸血鬼的故事。
You know, we've talked about how on the wall the writers have all these cards. Yeah. He was just handed two three by five cards. One said business school and the other said bat in the office. Well, look at that. A succinct note card give to go along with my succinct summary. And I guess business school was Greg's idea. He always knew at some point down the road he wanted to go to Ryan's business school.
我们当时说，每个人都说，这纯属巧合。好吧，伙计们，我们联系了编剧布伦特·福斯特。记得吗，他为我们的悲伤辅导那一集发送了许多精彩的音频片段。他这周又做了一次。这是他对此的看法。这一集由乔斯·韦登执导，他当时是一位伟大且成功的电视创作者，恰好是《办公室》的忠实粉丝。他找到我们，问他是否可以执导一集。他最终执导了两集。
And I guess that card had been on the wall for a while. Well, Angela, speaking of bat storylines, fast fact number one, Joss Whedon directed this episode. So Joss is famous for creating Buffy the Vampire Slayer, the series starring Sarah Michelle Geller. This was a huge hit on the WB Network, which was run at the time by Suzanne Daniels. Suzanne's husband is Greg Daniels. And that is how Joss kind of got his in to direct an episode of the show. But I guess it is just a pure coincidence that he got assigned the episode with a bat and a vampire storyline. I remember he was like, come on, guys, you gave me the bat vampire story.
这是他做的第一集。他执导的第一集恰好有一个吸血鬼次要情节，而他是《吸血鬼猎人巴菲》的创作者，这完全是巧合。你在那个吸血鬼次要情节中注意到我印象最深的是乔斯添加的这个视觉细节，它不在剧本中。如果你注意到吉姆和德怀特的吸血鬼次要情节结束时，吉姆说再见并在一天结束时离开办公室。他所做的是，他转身翻起衣领，并从肩膀上回头看了一眼。
And we were like, and everyone was like, it is pure coincidence. Well, guys, we reached out to writer Brent Forrester. Remember, he sent in so many amazing audio clips for our grief counseling episode. He did it again this week. And here's what he had to say about this. This episode was directed by Joss Whedon, who was a big, successful television creator at the time and happened to be a big fan of the office. And he approached us asking if he could direct an episode. He ended up directing two.
这是德古拉从斗篷角落看出来的完美形象，它作为一个视觉噱头效果非常好，不在剧本里，完全是一个在吸血鬼类型中工作了很长时间的人的贡献。那是纯粹的乔斯·韦登。我不知道这一点。我也不知道。你还记得当时吗，因为我也问过肯特·萨博纳克，他说在第二季之后，在我们赢得艾美奖之后，我们有一群导演联系我们想要执导我们的节目。记得像哈罗德·雷米斯，J.J. 艾布拉姆斯吗？杰森·雷特曼？是的。太疯狂了。肯特会根据导演的空档期分配剧本。他证实了乔斯就是这样得到这一集的。现在，第二个快速事实，肯特百科全书的位置解析。
And this was the first one that he did. And it's just a total coincidence that the first episode that he directed happens to have a vampire subplot in it and he was the creator of Buffy the Vampire Slayer. What you notice in that vampire subplot that I remember most is this visual detail that Joss added that was not in the script. If you notice at the end of the Jim Dwight vampire subplot, Jim says goodbye and leaves the office at the end of the day. And what he does, he turns and he flips up his collar and sort of looks over his shoulder.
哦，我们需要一个肯特百科全书位置解析的叮当声。肯特百科全书位置解析。你喜欢吗？还可以。我试着做那种学校摇滚风格的东西。是的，我喜欢。好的。好的，肯特百科全书位置解析，这是关于北岭的吗？
And it's the perfect image of Dracula looking over the corner of his cape. And it just works wonderfully as a visual gag, not in the script, totally the contribution of a guy who has worked a long time in the vampire genre. That was pure Joss Whedon. I did not know that. I didn't know it either. And you remember at this time, because I asked Kent Sabornack about this as well, he said that after season two, after we won the Emmy, we had a bunch of directors reaching out about directing our show. Remember like Harold Ramos, J.J. Abrams? Jason Wrightman? Yes. So crazy. And Kent would just assign scripts according to director availability. And that is, he confirms how Joss got this episode. So now, fast fact number two, location breakdown with Kentopedia.
是的。我们有一个粉丝问题，B. 史密斯，塔沃特少校。朱莉娅·李，梅根·米克，罗斯·科塞特和苔丝·施密特，商学院的场景在现实生活中是在哪里拍摄的？那是校园里真正的教室吗？那些是真正的学生还是演员？嗯，正如安吉拉所说，瑞安的商学院和帕姆的艺术学校的场景都是在加州州立大学北岭分校拍摄的。你是怎么知道那是加州州立大学北岭分校的，安吉拉？因为我听了 DVD 评论。哦，你们。嗯，肯特说教室里的所有学生都是雇来的临时演员，那天我们为教室场景总共使用了 122 名背景演员
Ooh, we need a jingle for Location Breakdown with Kentopedia. Location Breakdown with Kentopedia. Do you like it? That's okay. I was trying to do like a schoolhouse rock thing. Yeah, I like it. Okay. Okay, location breakdown with Kentapedia, is this about North Ridge?
和校园外观场景。他说商学院和外观场景是在第一天拍摄的，第二天我们拍摄了帕姆艺术展的场景，该展是在加州州立大学北岭分校设计中心举行的。我喜欢他们在 DVD 评论中谈论的一件事是，布伦特说他们要求所有扮演学生的演员，请带上他们自己的个人笔记本电脑。哦。当我观看那个场景时，珍娜，我注意到所有的笔记本电脑都不一样。那真是一个很好的细节。好的。第三个快速事实。是的。这一集播出九天后，雷恩·威尔逊主持了《周六夜现场》。哦，你记得这个吗？是的。我们为他感到非常兴奋。所以我们不得不稍微调整我们的拍摄时间表来让这个
Yes. We had a fan question, B. Smith, Major Tarwater. Julia Lee, Megan Meeker, Rose Cosette, and Tess Schmidt, where were the business school scenes shot in real life? Was it a real classroom on a campus? Were those real students or were they actors? Well, as Angela said, Ryan's Business School and the scenes with Pam's Art School were all shot at Cal State Northridge. How did you know it was Cal State Northridge, Ang? Because I listened to the DVD commentary. Oh, y'all's. Well, Kent said all of the students in the classroom were hired extras, that we used a total of 122 background actors that day for the classroom scenes
为雷恩发生，我只记得我们都为他感到非常兴奋。在他的开场独白中，他做了这个片段。太搞笑了，他说，哦，他只是太兴奋能参加《周六夜现场》了，因为它比拍摄《办公室》要令人兴奋得多，后者基本上就是整天坐在荧光灯下的桌子旁。他说，在《周六夜现场》的片场，有脚手架，有道具，有服装和假发，你知道，感觉像一个真正的节目。他说，让我展示给你看。让我展示给你看。他带着观众进行了一次后台参观，展示它是多么令人兴奋，结果发现《周六夜现场》的演员们穿着戏服，模仿我们《办公室》里的所有角色。是的。嗯，克里斯汀·韦格是帕姆
and the exterior campus scenes. He said that the business school and the exterior scenes were filmed on day one, and on day two, we filmed the scenes for Pam's art show, which was held in the Cal State Northridge Design Center. One of the things I liked that they talked about in the DVD commentary was Brent said they asked all the people playing students, if they would please bring their own personal laptop. Oh. And when I watched the scene, Jenna, I noticed that all the laptops were different. That is such a good detail. All right. Fast fact number three. Yeah. Nine days after this episode aired, Rain Wilson hosted Saturday Night Live. Oh, you remember this? Yes. We were so excited for him. So we had to kind of move around our shooting schedule to make this
她在接电话。是的。他说，嘿，克里斯汀。她说，SNL。嗨，我能帮你吗？她说，我只是在接电话。他说，你在做什么？她说，我经常这样做。我做很多事情。他说，你没做别的吗？她说，嗯，我也喜欢画画。然后她举起了一幅 30 洛克菲勒中心的彩色水彩画。
happened for rain, and I just remember we were all so excited for him. And during his opening monologue, he did this bit. It's so funny where he says, oh, he's just so excited to be at Saturday Night Live because it's just way more exciting than shooting the office, which is basically just sitting at a desk on our fluorescent lights all day. He was like, on the set of S&L, there's like scaffolding and there's props and there's costumes and wigs, you know, it feels like a real show. And he's like, let me show you. Let me show you. And he takes the audience on like this backstage tour to show how exciting it is only to find the cast of Saturday Night Live kind of dressed up doing impersonations of all of our characters from the office. Yes. Well, Kristen Wig is Pam
那是他们拍摄 SNL 的地方。这是对帕姆的邓德·米夫林水彩画这一集的回调。当我看到它时，我兴奋得快疯了。艾米·波勒扮演了我。哦，太搞笑了。而且，像，有这种，像，某种，像，咆哮，并且，像，有点和雷恩调情，扮演德怀特。如果你记得，珍娜，拉什达那个周末也在那里，她是许多 SNL 演员的朋友。所以他们就像，只是作为凯伦跳进去。
and she's answering phones. Yes. And he's like, hey Kristen. And she's like, S&L. Hi, can I help you? She was like, I'm just answering phones. And he's like, what are you doing? She's like, I do this all the time. I do a lot of things. He's like, don't you do anything else? And she's like, well, I also like to paint. And then she holds up a watercolor painting of 30 Rockefeller Center.
所以她做了。他走下大厅。是的。他们拍了所有这些照片，拉什达把它们发邮件给了我。她说，安，看，那是艾米扮演你。我有那天他们从片场拍的所有这些很棒的照片。太棒了。你要把那些放在播客上吗？
That's where they film S&L. And that is a callback to this episode that had just aired of Pam's watercolor of Dunder Mifflin. And I was freaking out excited when I saw it. Amy Poehler played me. Oh, it's so funny. And, like, had this, like, sort of, like, snarl and, like, kind of flirted with Rain as Dwight. And if you remember, Jenna, Rashida was there that weekend, and she's friends with a lot of the S&L cast members. So they were, like, just hop in as Karen.
在办公室女士播客上？是的，我会放一张。我有一张很棒的。我想我有一张合影。我会放在播客上。嗯，听听克里斯汀·韦格在那一集播出后做了什么。什么？所以她和我共用一个经理，我们见过几次面。
So she did. He walks down the hole. Yeah. And they took all these pictures, and Rashida emailed them to me. She was like, Anne, look, it's Amy as you. And I have all of these great pictures of them from the set that day. Amazing. Are you going to put those on the pod?
我们当时都是非常挣扎的女演员。当我在《办公室》时，她进入了《周六夜现场》。所以这对我们来说真的很令人兴奋。我收到一个包裹。是那幅水彩画。哦，得了吧。她在节目中举起的那幅。她在背面签了名，然后给我写了最贴心的便条，就像是，我只是知道如果我曾经在这个电视节目中被模仿，那对我意味着什么。我想你可能想拥有那一刻的道具。所以我问我是否可以把它寄给你，他们说可以。那太可爱了。是的，我把它装裱起来了，它在我的家庭室里。那太棒了，珍娜。我从来不知道。我去过你的家庭室无数次了。
On office ladies' pot? Yes, I'll put one. I have a great one. I think I have a group shot. I'll put on the pod. Well, listen to what Kristen Wigg did after that episode aired. What? So she and I shared a manager, and we'd met a few times.
是的，它在架子上，和格雷格为我们制作的《辛普森一家》卡通画在一起。那是我的两件珍藏品。下次我去你家时，我会找它的。她是最好的，伙计们。那太甜了。嗯，听着，这就是我所有的内容。我想我们应该休息一下，然后回来谈谈《商学院》，带上一堆来自布伦特的精彩音频片段和来自凯特·弗兰纳里的一个小特别惊喜。
We were both really struggling actresses at the same time. And kind of when I got on the office, she got on Saturday Night Live. So this was really thrilling to us. I get a package in the mail. It is the watercolor. Oh, come on. That she held up on the show. she signed the back of it, and then she wrote me the nicest note that was just like, I just know what it would mean to me if I were ever parodied on this television show. And I thought you might like to have a prop from the moment. So I asked if I could send this to you and they said yes. That is so lovely. Yeah, and I have it framed and it's in my family room. That is so great, Jenna. I never knew that. I've been in your family room a gazillion times.
是的。回头见。本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助。你知道，有时我们会转向一些有趣的地方寻求支持，也许是理发师，咖啡师，也许是浴室里的陌生人寻求生活建议，但并不是每个人都是治疗师。您可以在 BetterHelp 找到您的最佳匹配。BetterHelp 治疗师经过临床培训和认证。他们按照严格的行为准则工作，并在美国获得完全许可。
Yeah, it's up on the shelf with the Simpsons cartoon that Greg made of us. There's like my two treasured items. I'm going to look for it next time I'm at your house. She's the best, guys. That is so sweet. Well, listen, that's all I got. I think we should go to a break and then we'll come back and talk all about business school with a bunch of great audio clips from Brent and a little special surprise from Kate Flannery.
美国。BetterHelp 为您完成初步匹配工作，因此您可以专注于您的治疗目标。您将获得一份简短的问卷，有助于确定您的需求和偏好，然后他们会将您与持证治疗师匹配。作为世界上最大的在线治疗提供商，BetterHelp 可以提供接触具有多种专业知识的心理健康专业人员的机会。通过 BetterHelp 找到合适的人。我们的听众在 betterhelp.com/officeladies 上首次购买可享受 10% 的折扣。那是 betterhelp.com/officeladies。本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助。你知道，有时我们会转向一些有趣的地方寻求支持，也许是理发师，咖啡师，也许是浴室里的陌生人
Yes. We'll see you. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, sometimes we turn to some funny places for support, maybe a hairdresser, a barista, maybe a random stranger in the bathroom for life advice, but not everyone is a therapist. You can find your right match with BetterHelp. BetterHelp therapists are clinically trained and credentialed. They work according to a strict code of conduct and are fully licensed in the use.
寻求生活建议，但并不是每个人都是治疗师。您可以在 BetterHelp 找到您的最佳匹配。Better Help 治疗师经过临床培训和认证。他们按照严格的行为准则工作，并在美国获得完全许可。BetterHelp 为您完成初步匹配工作，因此您可以专注于您的治疗目标。您将获得一份简短的问卷，有助于确定您的需求和偏好，然后他们会将您与持证治疗师匹配。作为世界上最大的在线治疗提供商，BetterHelp 可以提供接触
U.S. And BetterHelp does the initial matching work for you, so you can focus on your therapy goals. You'll get a short questionnaire that helps identify your needs and preferences, and then they will match you with a licensed therapist. As the largest online therapy provider in the world, BetterHelp can provide access to mental health professionals with a diverse variety of expertise. Find the one with BetterHelp. Our listeners get 10% off their first month at betterhelp.com slash office ladies. That's betterhelp help.com slash office ladies. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, sometimes we turn to some funny places for support, maybe a hairdresser, a barista, maybe a random stranger in the bathroom
具有多种专业知识的心理健康专业人员的机会。通过 BetterHelp 找到合适的人。我们的听众在 BetterHelp.com/officeladies 上首次购买可享受 10% 的折扣。那是 BetterHelp, H-E-L-P.com/officeladies。好的，我们回来了，让我们进入这一集。伙计们，我们从凯文上班有点迟到开始。他说他差点死了，因为他的轮胎爆了。
for life advice, but not everyone is a therapist. You can find your right match with BetterHelp. Better Help therapists are clinically trained and credentialed. They work according to a strict code of conduct and are fully licensed in the U.S. And BetterHelp does the initial matching work for you, so you can focus on your therapy goals. You'll get a short questionnaire that helps identify your needs and preferences, and then they will match you with a licensed therapist. As the largest online therapy provider in the world, BetterHelp can provide access to
迈克尔不在乎。他不在乎。他只是不停地说，为什么今天是一个特殊的日子？珍娜，当他说，突击测验时，我唯一能想到的是基努·里维斯。为什么？因为《生死时速》。哦，是的。突击测验，混蛋。
mental health professionals with a diverse variety of expertise. Find the one with BetterHelp. Our listeners get 10% off their first month at BetterHelp.com slash office ladies. That's BetterHelp, H-E-L-P.com slash office ladies. Okay, we are back and let's get into this episode. You guys, we start with Kevin arriving a little late to work. And he says he almost died because his tire blew out.
你的头上瞄准了一个发触发器。你做什么？你做什么？你上次看这部电影是什么时候？三天前。嗯，我现在明白你为什么建立这种联系了。我知道。我真的很伤心迈克尔在这一刻没有做基努·里维斯的模仿。
Michael doesn't care. He doesn't care. He just keeps saying, why is today a special day? And Jenna, when he said, pop quiz, all I could think about was Keanu Reeves. Why? Because of speed. Oh, yeah. Pop quiz, asshole.
哦，好吧，那是一个错失的机会。我知道。那对我来说会是圆满的。它会让我非常高兴。但是是的。我记得拍摄这个场景。是的。这是我的问题。
You have a hair trigger aimed at your head. What do you do? What do you do? When's the last time you watched this movie? Three days ago. Well, I see now why you made the connection. I know. I'm really sad Michael didn't do a Keanu Reeves impression in this moment.
每当他们把布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳放在接待处做任何凯文的事情时，尤其是像受了伤的凯文，我就无法控制自己。当他在做悲伤的凯文时，我无法看着他。我不能。太搞笑了。嗯，迈克尔很兴奋，因为他要去瑞安的商学院。他太高兴了。
Oh, well, that's a missed opportunity. I know. That would have been full circle for me. It would have made me very happy. But yeah. I remember shooting this scene. Yeah. And here's my problem.
我们有一个瑞安的采访镜头，他说，看，如果我带我的老板去，我可以提升一个完整的字母等级。我应该。是的。我应该这样做。对吧？不。不，你不应该，瑞安。是的。我应该吗？
Whenever they would put Brian Baumgartner by reception to do anything Kevin, especially Kevin with like hurt feelings. I can't keep it together. I can't look at him when he is doing sad Kevin. I can't. So funny. Well, Michael's excited because he gets to go to Ryan's business school. And he's so happy.
嗯，我们要看看也许不，你不应该。但迈克尔只是很激动。我们有一个场景，德怀特在帮他打包。这引出了我最喜欢的德怀特采访镜头之一，这是一个著名的采访镜头。这是我最喜欢的之一。我的孩子们非常喜欢这个采访镜头，珍娜。迈克尔问他，我给过你最好的建议是什么？德怀特说，你给过我最好的建议，迈克尔，就是别当个白痴。
And we have a Ryan talking head where he's like, look, I get to go up a whole letter grade if I bring my boss in. I should. Yeah. I should do it. Right? No. No, you shouldn't, Ryan. Yeah.
它改变了我的人生。然后它切到了这个著名的、令人惊叹的采访镜头，德怀特看着卡梅伦说，每当我准备做某事时，我都会想，白痴会那样做吗？如果他们会，我就不做那件事。我喜欢它。我刚给一个 21 岁的年轻女性写了一张生日贺卡，我把这个写在她的卡片里了。我说，听着，那太聪明了。
Well, we're going to see maybe no, you shouldn't. But Michael is just thrilled. We have a scene where Dwight is helping him pack. And this leads us to one of my favorite Dwight talking heads, which is a famous talking head. It is one of my favorite. My kids love this talking head so much, Jenna. Michael's asking him, what is the best advice I ever gave you? And Dwight's like, the best advice you ever gave me, Michael, is don't be an idiot.
当你进入成年的下一个阶段时，记住德怀特·舒鲁特这些明智的话。是的，那太好了。所以我一直用这个。所以迈克尔和瑞安在车里，他说，伙计，你认为人们在我的演讲后会把帽子扔向空中吗？你知道，因为他们在毕业典礼或海军账户上有时会那样做。瑞安说，是的，这是，我不，这是，它只是，它不是那个场合。
It changed my life. And then it cuts to this famous, amazing talking head where Dwight looks at Cameron says, whenever I'm about to do something, I think, would an idiot do that? And if they would, I do not do that thing. I love it. I just wrote out a birthday card to a young woman who, was turning 21, and I put this in her card. I said, listen, that's brilliant.
我喜欢瑞安的这句台词，珍娜让我大声笑了出来，因为他说，你明白没有人毕业。是的。你必须知道瑞安现在吓得要死，因为他准备了一句台词，如果他们扔帽子的话。这就是那句台词。愿你们的帽子像你们的梦想一样飞得高。我见过人们把那句话写在他们的毕业帽上。我也见过。所以现在我们回到办公室。
As you move on to this next phase of adulthood, remember these wise words from Dwight Shrewd. Yes, that is so good. So I use this all the time. So then Michael's in the car with Ryan, and he's like, man, do you think people are going to throw their hats in the air after my speech? You know, because they do that sometimes in graduations or at naval accounts. And Ryan's like, yeah, this is, I don't, this is, it's just, it's not that. It's not that occasion.
这就是我们了解帕姆艺术展的时候，因为罗伊说他非常兴奋。我们有连续非常尴尬的帕姆和吉姆的采访镜头。是的。帕姆说，我很高兴和罗伊在一起。然后吉姆说，是的，帕姆和罗伊在一起。我是凯文。继续前进。你只是觉得，好吧，伙计们。我想他和凯伦在一起。我说谁？凯文。不，我没有。你说了。现在听着的每个人都听到你说了。哦，不。也许我应该喝一口
I loved this actual line from Ryan, Jenna made me laugh out loud because he says, you understand no one is graduating. Yes. And you've got to know Ryan is now crapping in his pants because he's like, he has a line prepared if they throw their hats. And this is the line. May your hats fly as high as your dreams. And I have seen people put that on their graduation hats for graduations. I have too. So now we go back to the office.
我的茶。也许我今天早上需要更多的咖啡因。让自己清醒点。你昨晚熬夜了。我是，女士。我是。我知道，因为我醒来时收到了一连串你发来的信息，大约在凌晨 12 点 30 分。我很抱歉。我没想到你。就像，是什么？它会提醒你吗？我关掉了提醒。不，不。是我醒来的时候。我醒来看着我的手机，我想，哇，因为我今天早上醒得很早，看到你发来的所有这些信息我很震惊。我想，哇，安吉拉今天也是个真正的早起鸟。看看我们。我说，不，它们是昨晚很晚发的。是的，它们是昨晚很晚发的。我没有熬夜当白痴。我是在，我是在工作。珍娜和我，你知道，我们还有其他事情。我没说你熬夜当
And this is when we learn about Pam's art show because Roy says he's really excited. We have back-to-back really awkward Pam and Jim talking heads. Yeah. Pam's like, I'm happy to be with Roy. And then Jim's like, yeah, Pam's with Roy. I'm Kevin. moving on. And you're just like, okay, guys. I think he's with Karen. Who did I say? Kevin. No, I didn't. You did. And everyone listening right now just heard you say. Oh, no. Maybe I should take a
白痴。不，我知道。我是在告诉那里的 21 岁年轻人。珍娜和我还有其他事情，伙计们，我们正在策划。我正在处理其中之一。我们有事情在酝酿。我昨晚很晚受到启发。好的。我喜欢它。我喝了一杯茶。我正在让自己清醒。我不会叫凯伦凯文。所以现在帕姆告诉凯莉关于她的艺术展，明迪的表演，她假装感兴趣并表现得好像她会去，真是太令人惊叹了。太完美了。是的。这就是我们所有人在被邀请参加我们知道我们不会去但我们说我们会去的事情时的情况。是的。哦，我会，是的。是的。是的。所有我绝对会去。
sip of my tea. Maybe I need more caffeine this morning. Wake yourself up. You were up late last night. I was, lady. I was. I know, because I woke up to a string of messages from you that were sent at like 12.30 in the morning. I'm so sorry. I didn't think you. Like, what is it? Does it alert you or something? I have my alerts off. No, no. It was when I woke up. I woke up and looked at my phone and I was like, wow, because I woke up really early this morning and I was shocked to see all these messages from you. I was like, wow, Angela's a real early bird today too. Look at us. And I was like, no, they were from late last night. Yeah, they were from really late last night. I wasn't up being an idiot. I was, I was working. Jen and I, you know, we have some other stuff. I didn't say you were up being
是的。嗯哼。我迫不及待了。好的。所以现在迈克尔到达了校园。他太兴奋了。他正在经历所有这些回忆，如果他曾经上过大学，这些回忆可能就会发生。顺便说一句，这让我很难过。
an idiot. No, I know. I'm telling the 21 year olds out there. Jen and I have some other stuff guys that were hatching up. And I was working on one of. of them. We have something brewing. I was inspired late last night. Okay. I like it. I've had a cup of tea. I'm waking myself up. I'm not going to call Karen Kevin. So now Pam tells Kelly about her art show, Mindy's performance where she feigns interest and acts like she's going to come is just freaking amazing. It's perfect. Yeah. It's all of us when we've been invited to something that we know we're not going to go to, but we're saying we're going to go to it. Yeah. Oh, I would, yes. Yes. Yes. All of I will absolutely be there.
我也很难过。我的意思是，迈克尔会喜欢大学的。我想迈克尔会像宿舍里的 RA 一样，你知道？百分之百。他可能就像一个终身 RA。他们可能就像，你现在可以走了。他说，不，我们还有一批学生要进来。他们说，你不再是学生了。
Yes. Uh-huh. I can't wait. All right. So now Michael arrives on campus. He is so excited. There's just all of these memories coming back to him that he's having that might have occurred if he had ever attended college. That made me sad, by the way.
是的。是的，那是真的。这是真的。嗯，我们有一个来自安布尔·莫里斯的粉丝评论。好的。你知道迈克尔跑过来试图加入飞盘游戏的那一刻吗？是的。她说，有趣的快速事实。
I made me sad, too. I mean, Michael would have loved college. I think Michael would have been like an RA in the dorm, you know? A hundred percent. And he probably would have been like a life for R.A. They probably would have been like, you can leave now. And he's like, no, we got another batch of students coming in. And they're like, you're not a student anymore.
我的一个朋友，内森·布兰克，扮演了飞盘学生。在瑞安的学校。迈克尔跑过来偷了一个飞盘并扔了出去，内森的台词大概是，伙计，他对他拍摄的那一天以及与史蒂夫和 BJ 一起工作只有美好的评价。啊，我喜欢那个。是的，那非常甜。那个场景让我笑得很厉害，因为史蒂夫接近那个飞盘的方式
Yeah. Yeah, that's true. It's true. Well, we had a fan comment from Amber Morris. Okay. You know that moment when Michael runs up and tries to join the Frisbee game? Yeah. She says, fun fast fact.
是错的。没有人应该那样抓飞盘并扔出去，它真是太完美了。嗯，现在我们要回到办公室，安吉拉，因为布伦特谈到的那张写着办公室里的蝙蝠的卡片，现在要开始发挥作用了。我们在办公室。德怀特看到某种动物粪便。他在调查。他说，哦，椽子里有一只鸟，伙计们。但那不是鸟。那是蝙蝠。
A friend of mine, Nathan Blank, played the Frisbee student. at Ryan's school. Michael ran up and stole a frisbee and threw it, and Nathan's line was something like, dude, and he has had nothing but wonderful things to say about his filming day and working with Steve and BJ. Aw, I love that. Yeah, that is very sweet. That scene made me laugh really hard because everything about how Steve approached that frisbee
每个人都吓坏了。除了吉姆和克里德。哦，是的，克里德准备好了。安吉拉趴下并滚动。是的。斯坦利离开了。最终，德怀特在经过一番混乱后能够把蝙蝠锁在会议室里。来自利奥娜·沃尔德里奇、露丝·罗德里格斯、希瑟·弗林和艾比·莫尔的粉丝问题。
was wrong. No one should ever grab a frisbee and throw it that way, and it just was so perfect. Well, now we're going to go back to the office, Angela, because now that other card that Brent talked about, the one that says bad in office, is about to go into play. We're in the office. Dwight sees some kind of animal feces. He's on the case. He's like, oh, there's a bird in the rafters, guys. But it's not a bird. It's a bat.
在大约五分钟时，安吉拉趴下并滚动，而蝙蝠在周围飞。然后你几乎听不到她在背景中的声音，要么是在自言自语，要么是在祈祷。你知道你在说什么吗？我知道。我记得乔斯对我说。我，好的，安吉拉会完全吓坏的。而且，你知道，我们谈论过那看起来像什么？我，我趴在地上。我想出了这个趴在地上并滚动。那是我的记忆，珍娜，我趴在地上，我决定滚动。乔斯真的
And everyone freaks out. Everyone except Jim and Creed. Oh, yeah, Creed is ready. Angela stops, drops and rolls. Yeah. Stanley leaves. Eventually, Dwight is able to lock the bat in the conference room after a bunch of mayhem. Fan question from Leona Waldridge, Ruth Rodriguez, Heather Flynn, and Abby Mole.
喜欢那个。然后我就脸朝下躺在地毯上。我即兴发挥了这个。我说了一些像，上帝，这是安吉拉·马丁。请不要让那个愚蠢的东西靠近我。我只是嘟囔着这些祈祷。我喜欢它。当我还是个孩子，我会祈祷时，我会以，上帝，这是珍娜·费舍尔开头。我会以介绍开头。一样。百分之百。是的。我想，嗯，我需要上帝知道，就像，我需要他喜欢锁定这些祈祷是给谁的？当我收到这些祈祷时，它们来自谁？所以我认为，嗯，我会以我的名字开头。我过去常说，主上帝，这是安吉拉·金赛。我在我的卧室里。我在印度尼西亚雅加达一条叫卡夫林的街道上。那是在南半球。
At approximately five minutes, Angela drops and rolls while the bat flies around. Then you barely hear her voice in the background, either talking to herself or praying. Do you know what you're saying? I do. I remember Joss saying to me. me, all right, Angela would totally freak out. And, you know, we talked about what did that look like? And what I, what I dropped to the ground. And I came up with this dropping to the ground and rolling. That's my memory, Jenna, that I dropped to the ground and I decided to roll. And Joss really
那是一群岛屿。我刚好在赤道下方。我要这样做。就像，我需要他知道我在哪里。那真是非常精确的位置定位。你就像，坐标是北纬 75 度。我在我的卧室里。它在走廊右侧。它在浴室对面。天哪，我没有那么具体，但我为那个鼓掌。谢谢。然后我们有更多关于这个场景的粉丝问题。来自罗莎莉·W、坦纳·W、米娅·F 和雅各布·W。
liked that. And then I just laid face down on the carpet. And I improvised this. And I said something like, God, this is Angela Martin. Please don't let that stupid thing come anywhere near me. And I just sort of mumbled these prayers. I love it. When I was a child and I would pray, I would lead with God, this is Jenna Fisher. I would lead with an introduction. Same. A hundred percent. Yeah. I was like, well, I need God to know, like, I need him to like key in to who are these prayers for? As I'm receiving these prayers, who are they coming from? So I thought, well, I'll lead with my name. I used to say, Lord God, this is Angela Kinsey. I'm in my bedroom. I am on a street called Kavling in Jakarta, Indonesia. That is in the southern hemisphere.
被困在办公室里的蝙蝠是真蝙蝠吗？肯特百科全书说，是的，我们为三个场景使用了真蝙蝠。德怀特站在帕姆接待处看天花板内部的场景，会议室天花板上蝙蝠的几个镜头，以及厨房天花板上蝙蝠的那个镜头。肯特雇了两个蝙蝠驯兽师为我们提供蝙蝠，查德·邓恩和约翰·鲍德温，
It's a group of islands. I'm just below the equator. I'm going to do this. Like, I needed him to know where I was. That was some serious location honing right there. You were like, the coordinates are 75 degrees latitude. I'm in my bedroom. It's down the hall on the right. It's a cross from the bathroom. My gosh, I did not get that specific, but I applaud that. Thank you. Then we had more fan questions about this scene. From Rosalie W. Tanner W., Mia F., and Jacob W.
他们把查德放在天花板上拿着蝙蝠，为了德怀特窥视的那个场景，就是我们刚才谈论的那个。现在，其余时间当我们看到蝙蝠飞来飞去时，那全是 CGI。肯特说他雇了米奇·萨斯金作为我们的视觉特效主管。他很棒，做得非常出色，他们与几家制作公司合作制作了蝙蝠动画。然后还有第三种蝙蝠，我们稍后会在与凯特的场景中谈论。是的。
Was the bat that got trapped in the office a real bat? Kintapedia says, Yes, we used a real bat for three scenes. the scene where Dwight stands on Pam's reception desk to look inside the ceiling, a few shots of the bat on the ceiling in the conference room, and for that shot of the bat on the ceiling in the kitchen. Kent hired two bat wranglers to provide us with the bat, Chad Dunn and John Baldwin,
那是一个机械蝙蝠。是的。所以三种不同的蝙蝠。三种不同的蝙蝠。我有一点点蝙蝠琐事。哦，告诉我。好的，这是我关于这一集的一点点蝙蝠琐事。在 DVD 评论中，雷恩说他给蝙蝠取了名字。
and they put Chad up in the ceiling to hold the bat for that scene where Dwight peers in, the one we were just talking about. Now, the rest of the time when we see the bat flying around, that was all CGI. Kent said he hired Mitch Suskin as our visual effects supervisor. He was great, did a terrific job, and they worked with several production houses to animate the bat. And then there was a third kind of bat that we used, which we will talk about later in the scene with Kate. Yes.
他当时在和蝙蝠驯兽师说话，雷恩说，他叫什么名字？蝙蝠驯兽师说，哦，我们从来没给他取过名字。雷恩说，什么？我要给他取名。所以雷恩给蝙蝠取名为加里。是加里，加里蝙蝠。我们整周都叫他加里。周。嗯，干得好，加里。是的。现在我的问题是，雷恩，如果你听这个，
And it was a mechanical bat. Yes. So three different bats. Three different bats. I have a tiny bit of bat trivia. Oh, lay it on me. Okay, here's my little bit of bat trivia from this episode. In the DVD commentary, Rain says he named the bat.
那是迈克尔·加里·斯科特吗？哦。哦。还是只是加里？只是加里蝙蝠。嗯，我记得拍摄这个场景，安吉拉，因为他们为我们布置了这个非常复杂的蝙蝠飞行路径，这样我们都可以对它做出反应，因为我们对虚无做出反应。没有东西飞过天花板。对。所以它真的编排好了。就像，蝙蝠在这里，蝙蝠在那里，蝙蝠在这里俯冲，蝙蝠进入会议室。而且，它看起来太真实了。
That he was talking to the bat wrangler, and Rain said, what's his name? And the bat wrangler was like, oh, we've never given him a name. And Rain was like, what? I'm going to name him. And so Ray named the bat, Gary. It's Gary, Gary the bat. And we called him Gary all week. week. Well, good job, Gary. Yeah. And now my question is, Rain, if you ever listen to this,
是的。所以是的，伙计们，我们对着办公室里飞过的虚无尖叫并做出反应。是的，我们没有吓坏蝙蝠。我们没有对他尖叫。我从这个场景中得到了一些背景捕捉。告诉我。三分钟 54 秒。帕姆正在画一个胶带分配器。
is that Michael Gary Scott? Oh. Oh. Or is it just Gary? Just Gary the bat. Well, I remember shooting this scene, Angela, because they laid out for us this very elaborate trail of how the bat would fly so that we could all react to it because we're reacting to nothing. Nothing is flying through the ceiling. Right. And so it was really choreographed. Like, bat is here, bat is there, bat swoops here, bat goes into conference room. And I, it looks so real.
是的，但我们在艺术展上没看到它。嗯，她在艺术展前没时间画那个水彩画。嗯，我不知道。这只是她在旁边做的事情吗？嗯，这就是我要问的，她是最后一分钟试图为她的墙多弄点艺术品吗？不，她只是有一个轻松的工作日，她在桌子上画画。好的。四分钟 26 秒，雷恩的屁股就在你脸上。
Yeah. So yeah, guys, we are screaming at and reacting to nothing flying through the office. Yeah, we're not freaking out the bat. We're not screaming at him. I have a few background catches from the scene. Lay them on me. Three minutes, 54 seconds. Pam is sketching a tape dispenser.
超级就在我脸上。超级就在你脸上。你就像，德怀特，你在做什么？他的屁股就在你脸上。是的。雷恩认为那非常有趣。我相信你也是。我不会给你深入了解蝙蝠。
Yeah, we don't see it though at the art show. Well, she doesn't have time to watercolor that before the art show. Well, I didn't know. This is just something she's doing on the side? Well, that's what I was going to ask, is she last minute trying to hustle up some more art for her wall? No, she just has a light work day and she's sketching at her desk. Okay. At four minutes, 26 seconds, Rain's butt is right in your face.
我很震惊。但我、我的孩子们听了这个很棒的播客。它是为家庭和孩子准备的，叫《Smash Boom Best》。他们做的是，他们让两个人辩论两件不同的事情，然后一个孩子决定哪一个更好。哦，可爱。他们有一个，太可爱了。所以他们有一个叫蝙蝠对猫头鹰。如果你想了解一些关于蝙蝠和猫头鹰的很酷的东西，我推荐这个播客，因为我们很喜欢它。
Super right in my face. Super right in your face. You're like, Dwight, what are you doing? His butt is right in your face. Yeah. Rain thought that was very fun. I'm sure you did. I'm not going to give you a deep dive on bats.
就在我脸上。就在你脸上。你当时就像是，德怀特，你在干什么？他的屁股就在你脸上。是啊。雷恩觉得这很有趣。我肯定你也是这么想的。我不会给你深入讲解蝙蝠的。
I am shocked. But me and my kids listen to this amazing podcast. It's four families and kids called Smash Boom Best. And what they do is they have two people debate two different things and then a kid decides which one is better. Oh, cute. And they had a really, it's so cute. So they had one called Bats versus Owls. And if you want to learn some really cool stuff about bats and owls, I recommend this podcast because we loved it.
我很震惊。但我跟我孩子们在听这个很棒的播客。它是由四个家庭和孩子们制作的，叫《Smash Boom Best》。他们的节目形式是让两个人辩论两件不同的事物，然后由一个孩子来决定哪个更好。哦，真可爱。他们有一期，真的，太可爱了。他们做了一期叫《蝙蝠对猫头鹰》。如果你想了解一些关于蝙蝠和猫头鹰的很酷的知识，我推荐这个播客，因为我们非常喜欢它。
They eat a ton of mosquitoes, guys, especially in Texas. There's this huge swarm of bats that's responsible for really controlling the mosquito population. And their feces can be used as energy. Uh-oh, I maybe am telling you some bad facts. I know. Now you're telling us bat facts. Toby has a fantastic talking head during all this chaos, and he's like, you know, the simple solution would just be to open a window. But none of our windows open. That's a little creepy. It really is. Well, Angela, then you have a talking head where you say, I can't even say it. This is one of my most quoted lines to me. You know, like when you meet fans of the show and they quote a line to you, this is one of the lines. Strangers would come up to me and be like, poop, is raining from the ceilings. Poop! It's so good. Angela, We had a fan question from Jackie Kay.
它们吃掉大量的蚊子，伙计们，尤其是在德克萨斯州。有一大群蝙蝠负责真正控制蚊子的数量。它们的粪便还可以用作能源。呃，我可能在告诉你们一些错误的知识。我知道。现在你在给我们讲蝙蝠知识了。托比在这一片混乱中有一个精彩的采访镜头，他说，你知道，简单的解决办法就是打开窗户。但我们的窗户都打不开。这有点令人毛骨悚然。确实是。好吧，安吉拉，然后你有一个采访镜头，你说，我甚至说不出口。这是我被引用最多的台词之一。你知道，当你见到节目的粉丝，他们引用台词给你听时，这就是其中之一。陌生人会走过来对我说，屎，正从天花板上掉下来。屎！太棒了。安吉拉，我们有一个来自杰基·凯的粉丝提问。
How many takes did it require for Angela to get the poop is raining from the ceiling talking head? We did a few because we were playing around with what type of distress was this for Angela? Was she angry, are terrified, scared, annoyed? So we did a few, and the one they picked was where I'm actually concerned and scared. And I have my rain bonnet on. I was going to say, the rain bonnet. is everything. Everything.
安吉拉拍“屎正从天花板上掉下来”那个采访镜头拍了多少次？我们拍了几次，因为我们在尝试安吉拉当时处于什么样的痛苦中？她是生气、恐惧、害怕还是恼火？所以我们拍了几次，他们选中的那次是我表现得真的很担心和害怕。而且我戴着防雨帽。我正想说，防雨帽。是一切。一切。
Angela, my grandmother had one of those. Yes. My grandmother got her hair done once a week. Same. And it would be the same hairdo. It was set for the whole week. Yeah, that's what the ladies used to do. They used to have their weekly appointment.
安吉拉，我祖母也有一个那样的。是的。我祖母每周做一次头发。我也是。而且发型都一样。整个星期都定型了。是的，那是女士们过去常做的事。她们过去有每周的预约。
They'd get their hair washed and set and then just teased and sprayed. Yeah. And then my grandma had this little rain bonnet folded up in her purse. And if there was even a sprinkle. She would throw. Throw that thing on. Yes. Same with my grandmother.
她们会洗头、定型，然后梳理和喷发胶。是的。然后我祖母会在钱包里折叠一个小防雨帽。如果哪怕有一点点毛毛雨。她就会扔。把那东西扔在头上。是的，我祖母也一样。
I have so many memories of her putting it on going to church because there was just maybe a tiny, tiny bit of missed. I was just tickled by this scene because it made me think of my grandmother. And I love that Angela Martin keeps one on hand. She has a rain bonnet ready to go. When I saw it, I thought we need to bring back this rain bonnet. I looked online. There's a lot you can buy now.
我有太多关于她去教堂时戴上它的记忆，因为可能只有一点点细雨。我被这个场景逗乐了，因为它让我想起了我的祖母。我喜欢安吉拉·马丁随身携带一个。她准备好了一个防雨帽。当我看到它时，我想我们需要把这个防雨帽带回来。我在网上查了。现在有很多可以买到。
And you know I love a good pun. There is a company that makes one. And they call it a hairbrella. I want a hairbrella. Well, Jim calls animal control, and they say they're going to be there by 6 o'clock. But Dwight finds this unacceptable. Yeah. But this is when Jim starts his prank on Dwight.
而且你知道我喜欢双关语。有一家公司生产这种产品。他们称之为“发伞”（hairbrella）。我想要一把发伞。好吧，吉姆打电话给动物管制中心，他们说6点钟会到。但德怀特觉得这不可接受。是的。但这就是吉姆开始捉弄德怀特的时候。
He's distracted by this bite on his neck, and he's just feeling like really tingly and strangely powerful. Huh. Can't explain it. That's all he has to do. And Dwight fills in all the blanks. Well, now back at the business school, Michael is in like a sound booth watching Ryan sort of give an introduction is what he thinks, right? But Ryan is basically telling the classroom that Dunder Mifflin can't compete with the bigger chains. He thinks this whole business is going to be obsolete in like five years.
他被脖子上的咬痕分心了，感觉真的很刺痛，而且有一种奇怪的强大感。哈。无法解释。他只需要做这些。而德怀特填补了所有空白。好吧，现在回到商学院，迈克尔在一个隔音室里，看着瑞安做介绍，他以为是这样，对吧？但瑞安基本上是在告诉教室，邓德·米夫林无法与更大的连锁店竞争。他认为整个生意在五年内就会过时。
And in fact, he thinks the management isn't flexible and able to adapt. And you know what I wrote? What? Ryan, how dare you? You know what this means to Michael. How dare you set him up like that? Look, if that conversation was going to come out in the classroom on its own, fine. But Ryan could have set him up differently. He could have said, you know what, guys, Dunder Mifflin is a small company. It has a harder time competing. But you know what? Management really believes in it. They really believe in like a one-on-one personal connection. And my boss is someone, he's sort of part of a dying breed of a traditional salesman. He's being a total punk in this moment. I think so. Well, then when Michael takes the stage, thinking he's been introduced in a totally different, more flattering way, he enters with his own musical fanfare.
事实上，他认为管理层不够灵活，无法适应。你知道我写了什么吗？什么？瑞安，你怎么敢？你知道这对迈克尔意味着什么。你怎么敢那样陷害他？听着，如果那段对话在课堂上自然发生，那没关系。但瑞安本可以以不同的方式引导他。他本可以说，你知道吗，伙计们，邓德·米夫林是一家小公司。它竞争起来比较困难。但你知道吗？管理层真的很相信它。他们真的很相信一对一的个人联系。而我的老板是那种人，他算是传统推销员中濒临灭绝的一类。他此刻表现得完全是个混蛋。我也这么认为。好吧，当迈克尔走上台时，以为自己是以一种完全不同、更讨人喜欢的方式被介绍的，他带着自己的音乐伴奏入场了。
He shows up. He shows up with his boombox. Yeah. He's playing like classical music. That's a bold move. No matter how Ryan set you up, even if Ryan had painted you in an amazing light, to walk in. With your boombox playing, your intro song is really, it's a really bold move. Knowing everything we know about Michael, it's surprising that he didn't show up dressed as a character to inspire the students.
他出现了。他带着他的音箱出现了。是的。他放着古典音乐。这是一个大胆的举动。无论瑞安如何介绍你，即使瑞安把你描绘得非常出色，带着你的音箱走进来，播放你的入场曲，这真的是一个非常大胆的举动。了解关于迈克尔的一切，令人惊讶的是他没有打扮成一个角色来激励学生。
But he has come as himself. But he does bring props. Oh, does he ever? Well, he starts by tearing up someone's book as a way of inspiring them. And then he moves into his candy bar. runner, pun. Then he lets the classroom know there are four kinds of businesses. Number one, tourism. Number two, food service. Number three, railroads. Number four, sales. Number five, hospital and manufacturing, and then also air travel. My favorite is hospital slash manufacturing. I know. So then he moves into his
但他以自己的身份来了。但他确实带了道具。哦，他带了吗？好吧，他开始撕毁某人的书作为激励他们的一种方式。然后他进入了他的糖果棒双关语。然后他让教室知道有四种生意。第一，旅游业。第二，餐饮服务。第三，铁路。第四，销售。第五，医院和制造业，还有航空旅行。我最喜欢的是医院/制造业。我知道。所以他进入了他的
Candy Bar puns. Oh, yeah. So good. So good. Do you know who wrote this whole scene? Who? Jen Salata. Oh, that makes so much sense.
糖果棒双关语。哦，是的。太好了。太好了。你知道是谁写了整个场景吗？谁？简·萨拉塔。哦，这就说得通了。
It's so great, isn't it? Well, we had a lot of people write in. Sammy Saul's Allie Stecklein, Lily McGrath all asked how much of Michael's speech to Ryan's business class was improvised. Guys, basically none of it. It was almost like I went to the script. It's basically all scripted. What you see there in the episode, scripted. Yeah, you know, we didn't get to be there, Jenna.
太棒了，不是吗？好吧，我们有很多观众写信来。萨米·索尔斯、艾莉·斯特克莱恩、莉莉·麦格拉思都问迈克尔对瑞安商学院班级的演讲有多少是即兴发挥的。伙计们，基本上没有。几乎就像我照着剧本念一样。基本上全是剧本写的。你在剧集中看到的内容，是剧本写的。是的，你知道，我们没能去现场，珍娜。
To be in that classroom, it looked like so much fun. So we asked Brent Forrester, what was it like to shoot those scenes with Michael and the students? And here's what he had to say. Filming the business school scenes with Steve Correll in that lecture hall full of kids was really unforgettable. And I kind of suspected that it was. was going to go great because I knew that Steve had come from this live performance tradition with Second City and he really thrives on that live audience connection. And here was a chance for him to perform both in front of a camera and in front of a live audience of kids who at this
能在那个教室里，看起来太有趣了。所以我们问布伦特·福雷斯特，和迈克尔以及学生们拍摄那些场景是什么感觉？这就是他要说的。与史蒂夫·卡瑞尔在那个坐满孩子的演讲厅里拍摄商学院场景真的令人难忘。我当时有点怀疑这会进行得很顺利，因为我知道史蒂夫来自“第二城市”（Second City）的现场表演传统，他真的很擅长那种与现场观众的联系。这是一个让他既在摄像机前，又在现场观众面前表演的机会，这些孩子当时都是《办公室》的粉丝。我们当时在第三季。我记得拍摄过程是这样的，史蒂夫表演场景，然后观众席上的孩子们必须假装对他的讲座印象不深。所以他们会坐在那里保持沉默。然后助理导演喊停。然后整群孩子就会爆发出他们整个场景中一直压抑的笑声。所以一遍又一遍，史蒂夫表演，沉默，停，大笑。然后在最后一个场景的最后一次拍摄中，史蒂夫表演，一片沉默。助理导演喊停。史蒂夫的戏份杀青了。观众席上的孩子们爆发出笑声，他们站起来，给了他持续不断的掌声。
time were all fans of the office. We were in season three at this point. What I remember is the way these takes would go, Steve would perform the scene and then the kids in the audience would have to pretend that they were very unimpressed by his lecture. And so they would sit there in silence. And then the assistant director would call cut. And then the whole group of kids would just burst out into laughter that they'd been repressing through the whole scene. So over and over again, it was Steve performs, silence, cut, huge laugh. Then in the final take of the final scene, Steve performs, there's silence. The AD says cut. That's a wrap for Steve. The audience of Kids burst in the laughter, they stand up and they give him this ovation that went on forever.
（注：原文索引78与77内容重叠，此处按原文顺序翻译）
I was standing next to Steve at the time, and I saw the tears come to his eyes. It was so beautiful, one of the highlights for sure of my time on the office. Oh, my gosh. I wish I could have been there. I bet it felt so magical to those kids, you know. And to Steve, too, he basically had this whole audience just for himself. And kind of what Brent was talking about, which is that Steve started in. live performance.
我当时站在史蒂夫旁边，我看到他的眼眶湿润了。太美了，绝对是我在《办公室》期间的亮点之一。哦，天哪。我真希望我当时能在场。我敢说这对那些孩子来说感觉太神奇了，你知道。对史蒂夫也是，他基本上拥有了整个观众，只为他一个人。这有点像布伦特所说的，史蒂夫是从现场表演开始的。
Yeah. And I did, too, with theater, Angela, and it was a big adjustment to be sort of acting into a void, which is the camera. You don't get to see your jokes land. You don't get to hear people in their living rooms at home, you know, moving through your performance with you like you do in a theater situation. So it's always fun to get to perform for a live audience. Always, always.
是的。我也是，通过戏剧，安吉拉，适应那种对着虚空表演，也就是摄像机，是一个很大的调整。你无法看到你的笑话是否奏效。你听不到家里客厅里的人们，你知道，像在剧院那样随着你的表演而动。所以能为现场观众表演总是很有趣。总是，总是。
That was my whole, you know, every week doing an improv show. And it is a real energy to have a room like that with you and in the moment with you. It just always kind of makes my skin tingle. All right. So should we go check in at Dundra Mifflin now because Dwight is making a trap for the bat using a box and some glue. Yeah. So poor bad. Terrible.
那是我的全部，你知道，每周做即兴表演。拥有那样一个和你在一起、和你处于同一时刻的房间，确实有一种真正的能量。它总是让我起鸡皮疙瘩。好吧。那么我们现在去邓德·米夫林看看吧，因为德怀特正在用盒子和胶水为蝙蝠设陷阱。是的。所以可怜的蝙蝠。太糟糕了。
Yeah. And in the background, Jim and Karen are continuing this prank. Yeah. Karen is doing it, not Pam. I noticed. And I don't, I mean, I don't want to be. Oh, here it comes. I mean, was Pam better at pranking?
是的。在背景中，吉姆和凯伦正在继续这个恶作剧。是的。是凯伦在做，不是帕姆。我注意到了。而且我，我是说，我不想成为。哦，来了。我是说，帕姆更擅长恶作剧吗？
You said it. I mean, yes. I feel like Jim and Karen's prank is a little presentational and a little on the nose. And I think that when Pam, Pam pranks Dwight with Jim. It's more subtle and creative. I don't know. Yeah.
你说了。我是说，是的。我觉得吉姆和凯伦的恶作剧有点表演性质，有点直白。而且我认为当帕姆，帕姆和吉姆一起捉弄德怀特时。它更微妙、更有创意。我不知道。是的。
Well, you know, it's really hard to have the finesse of, like, drinking your water by the water cooler and, you know, covering up whatever Jim is doing by drinking a little cup of water and looking around. I mean, that is hard. That doesn't come natural. I knew you were going to bring that up. I knew you were going to bring that up because it's the one time that Pam is terrible. at pranking. It makes me laugh. It makes me laugh.
好吧，你知道，要拥有那种在饮水机旁喝水，你知道，通过喝一小杯水并环顾四周来掩盖吉姆正在做的事情的技巧，真的很难。我是说，那很难。那不是天生的。我就知道你会提起这个。我就知道你会提起这个，因为这是帕姆在恶作剧方面表现最差的一次。这让我发笑。这让我发笑。
But I'm sorry, her other pranks are very good. But yes, so they have this whole bit where, like, Jim can't pick up her piece of bread. It's white hot. Because it's garlic bread. And it's burning his hands. And she's like, this is ice cold. And then we go into, I mean, it's a little bit of heartbreak in the break room again. But it's Toby. Oh, yeah, it's Toby has some heartbreak. I mean, you guys, Toby is in love with Pam. And here is his opportunity to see her outside of work and maybe dazzle her somehow with his knowledge of art and support her. And it's the same evening of his daughter's play. And he's devastated. And he's even trying to think of a way to get out of going to see his child's play. I know. He's like, it's just we need to support local art.
但我很抱歉，她其他的恶作剧都非常好。但是是的，他们有整个片段，比如，吉姆拿不起她的那块面包。它烫得要命。因为那是大蒜面包。它烫伤了他的手。而她说，这冰凉冰凉的。然后我们进入，我是说，休息室里又有一点心碎。但那是托比。哦，是的，是托比有一些心碎。我是说，伙计们，托比爱上了帕姆。这是他看到她工作之外的样子，并可能以某种方式用他的艺术知识让她眼花缭乱并支持她的机会。而这正是他女儿演出的同一个晚上。他崩溃了。他甚至在想办法不去参加他孩子的演出。我知道。他说，这只是我们需要支持当地艺术。
And what they're doing is not art. Let's be on. And Pam's like, you should go see your child's play. Yes. Yes. Oh. Well, lady, while this is going on, back at the school, they're starting to get into the Q&A part, right? And the students are starting to ask Michael questions.
而他们所做的事情不是艺术。让我们诚实点。帕姆说，你应该去看看你孩子的演出。是的。是的。哦。好吧，女士，当这一切发生时，回到学校，他们开始进入问答环节，对吧？学生们开始问迈克尔问题。
Things are kind of falling apart. There's a moment, Jenna, I love so much. I love it when Michael says, real business is done on paper, write that down, and they all type. Yeah, it's just a sound of keyboards. Yes, that's a very fun joke in the script, too. Like, it says the students all get out their computers and begin typing. It's so good. So the students start asking him, how would you keep a client from leaving Dunder Mifflin for a nationwide
事情有点失控了。有一个时刻，珍娜，我非常喜欢。我喜欢迈克尔说，真正的生意是在纸上完成的，把它写下来，然后他们都开始打字。是的，那只是一阵键盘声。是的，那在剧本里也是一个非常有趣的笑话。比如，它写着学生们都拿出电脑开始打字。太棒了。所以学生们开始问他，你会如何阻止客户离开邓德·米夫林去选择全国性的
wide chain. And Michael's like, I don't need to persuade them to come back. They'll just come back eventually when they realize what a debacle it is to go to anyone else. And then the student's like, well, has anyone ever come back? And Michael's like, I don't want them back because they're stupid. Michael is starting to take this personal. He's getting his feelings hurt. And that is when one of the students points out, even your own employee says that Dunder Mifflin is going to be obsolete in five to ten years. Oh. I mean, this is just like a sucker punch.
连锁店。迈克尔说，我不需要说服他们回来。当他们意识到去别人那里是多么大的灾难时，他们最终会回来的。然后学生问，好吧，有人回来过吗？迈克尔说，我不想要他们回来，因为他们很蠢。迈克尔开始把这当成个人问题了。他受到了伤害。就在这时，其中一个学生指出，甚至你自己的员工都说邓德·米夫林在五到十年内就会过时。哦。我是说，这就像重重一击。
Michael is so hurt. Yeah. So now, back at the office, Dwight has formed an allegiance with Creed. What I love about this, Jenna, is that Dwight couldn't even get a sentence out. He was like, listen, Creed, I need an alliance. He's like, sure. Like, Creed is just like, Rets to go. He is up for it.
迈克尔太受伤了。是的。所以现在，回到办公室，德怀特和克里德结成了联盟。我喜欢这一点的是，珍娜，德怀特甚至没能说出一句完整的话。他说，听着，克里德，我需要一个联盟。他说，当然。就像，克里德只是说，准备好了。他对此很赞同。
He has a drawer of tools. So does Dwight. They're, I mean, they're meant to be. Yeah. Dwight asks him, can you turn a wooden mop handle into a steak and Creed is like what size? Yeah. He's got a drawer of mung beans and weaponry, apparently. Well, Jenna, I think this is a great time to take a break because when we come back, Dwight and Creed are going to catch a bat.
他有一个装满工具的抽屉。德怀特也有。他们，我是说，他们是天生一对。是的。德怀特问他，你能把木制拖把柄变成木桩吗？克里德问什么尺寸？是的。他显然有一个装满绿豆和武器的抽屉。好吧，珍娜，我认为现在是休息的好时机，因为当我们回来时，德怀特和克里德要抓一只蝙蝠。
With its 626 horsepower twin-turbo V8 engine, the defender, Octa, is taking on the Dakar rally. The ultimate off-road challenge. Learn more at landrover.ca. Wait, I didn't get charged for my donut. It was free with his Tim's rewards points. I think I just stole it. I'm a donut stealer.
凭借其626马力的双涡轮增压V8发动机，卫士Octa正在参加达喀尔拉力赛。终极越野挑战。在landrover.ca了解更多信息。等等，我的甜甜圈没收费。用他的Tim's奖励积分是免费的。我想我刚才偷了它。我是个甜甜圈小偷。
Oof. Earn points so fast, it'll seem too good to be true. Plus, join Tim's rewards today and get it. enough points for a free donut, drink, or timpits. With 800 points after registration, activation, and first purchase of a dollar or more, see the Tim's app for details at participating in restaurants in Canada for a limited time. Summer's here, and you can now get almost anything you need for your sunny days, delivered with Uber Eats. What do we mean by almost? Well, you can't get a well-groom lawn delivered, but you can get a chicken parmesan delivered.
呜。赚取积分如此之快，看起来好得令人难以置信。另外，今天加入Tim's奖励，获得足够的积分换取免费甜甜圈、饮料或Timbits。注册、激活并首次购买一美元或以上后可获得800积分，详情请参阅Tim's应用程序，在加拿大参与活动的餐厅限时提供。夏天到了，你现在几乎可以得到你阳光明媚的日子里需要的一切，通过Uber Eats配送。我们说的“几乎”是什么意思？好吧，你不能让人配送修剪整齐的草坪，但你可以让人配送鸡肉帕尔马干酪。
A cabana? That's a no, but a banana, that's a yes. A nice tan, sorry, nope. But a box fan, happily yes. Day of Sunshine? No. A box of fine wines? Yes. Uber Eats can definitely get you that. Get almost, almost anything delivered with Uber Eats. Order now. Alcohol and select markets. Product availability may vary by Regency App for details. All right, guys. So Creed and Dwight are on a mission. They are going to catch this bat before 6 p.m. Before the professionals of animal control arrive, they're going to take care of this problem. And Kelly begs them, because Crete has now gone into the supply closet.
凉亭？那是不可能的，但香蕉，那是可以的。漂亮的晒黑，抱歉，不行。但箱式风扇，很高兴可以。阳光明媚的一天？不行。一箱好酒？可以。Uber Eats绝对能为你做到。通过Uber Eats配送几乎、几乎任何东西。现在下单。酒精和特定市场。产品供应情况可能因地区而异，详情请参阅应用程序。好吧，伙计们。所以克里德和德怀特正在执行任务。他们要在下午6点之前抓住这只蝙蝠。在动物管制中心的专业人员到达之前，他们要解决这个问题。凯莉恳求他们，因为克里德现在已经进入了供应室。
He's grabbing some kind of spray. And Kelly's like, do not hurt that bat. It has feelings, and she just makes this big plea for the bat safety. And it comes flying into the main area. And then Kelly immediately screams, kill it, kill it, kill it. Yes, exactly. The bat flies into the little kitchen area. and Kevin closes the door.
他正在抓某种喷雾。凯莉说，不要伤害那只蝙蝠。它有感情，她为蝙蝠的安全发出了巨大的呼吁。然后它飞进了主区域。然后凯莉立刻尖叫，杀了它，杀了它，杀了它。是的，完全正确。蝙蝠飞进了小厨房区域，凯文关上了门。
So now that bat is trapped inside and Kevin is like, oh my gosh, I am a hero. I am a hero. Kevin's day has gone from a near-death experience to being a hero. He is having a day. Why do I feel like that's like Kevin's every day? Every day Kevin thinks he's a hero over a really mundane thing that's not quite heroic.
所以现在那只蝙蝠被困在里面了，凯文说，哦，天哪，我是个英雄。我是个英雄。凯文的一天从濒死体验变成了英雄。他今天过得真充实。为什么我觉得这就像凯文的每一天？每一天凯文都认为自己因为一件非常平凡、并不怎么英勇的事情而成了英雄。
You might be right. Yeah, I mean, Kevin thinks he saved everyone in the office, but, guys, not everyone was out of the kitchen. Meredith had gone to the bathroom. Well, we're going to leave her in there for a while because we're going back to Ryan's class. It's getting ugly. It's getting ugly. Michael is grasping at straws. He's so offended. He's taking it personal. And he's just starting all kinds of stuff. Yeah, he's like, guys, this is a David and Goliath situation. But remember, David always wins, and it's just like America. America is facing five Goliaths. Five.
你可能是对的。是的，我是说，凯文认为他拯救了办公室里的每个人，但是，伙计们，并不是每个人都离开了厨房。梅雷迪思去洗手间了。好吧，我们要让她在那里待一会儿，因为我们要回到瑞安的课上。情况变得糟糕了。情况变得糟糕了。迈克尔在做最后的挣扎。他太被冒犯了。他把它当成了个人问题。他开始制造各种麻烦。是的，他说，伙计们，这是一个大卫和歌利亚的情况。但记住，大卫总是赢，这就像美国。美国正面临五个歌利亚。五个。
And then he lists them off. It's like Al-Qaeda, global warming, sex predators, mercury poisoning. This is when Michael points out, you know what, Ryan has never made a sale. And he started a fire trying to make a cheesy pita. That made me laugh out loud. And then he said, and everyone thinks he's a tease. Amazing. And then he says, you know what, Ryan doesn't know anything and neither do you. So suck on that and he storms out of the classroom. He is so hurt. If you're Ryan, what are you thinking right now? Because you now know, you rode there with him. You are going to have to ride back to work with this person. That is uncomfortable. Michael tells Ryan, business is always personal, Ryan. I mean, that says everything you need to know about Michael, but we know this. Well, I respect that about him. I respect that about Michael. That business isn't business.
然后他列举了它们。就像基地组织、全球变暖、性掠夺者、汞中毒。就在这时，迈克尔指出，你知道吗，瑞安从来没有做成过一笔生意。而且他试图做芝士皮塔饼时引发了一场火灾。这让我大声笑了出来。然后他说，而且每个人都认为他是个讨厌鬼。太棒了。然后他说，你知道吗，瑞安什么都不知道，你们也一样。所以去死吧，然后他冲出了教室。他太受伤了。如果你是瑞安，你现在在想什么？因为你现在知道，你是和他一起开车去的。你还得和这个人一起开车回公司。那太尴尬了。迈克尔告诉瑞安，生意总是私人的，瑞安。我是说，这说明了你需要知道关于迈克尔的一切，但我们知道这一点。好吧，我尊重他这一点。我尊重迈克尔这一点。生意不是生意。
Business is always personal. And that, you know, he's going to say this later. A business is made up of people. I liked it. He tells Ryan, when we get back to the office, you better pack your things. This now starts one of my favorite storylines. Pam is finally at her art show. She's waiting for people to arrive.
生意总是私人的。而且，你知道，他稍后会说这个。生意是由人组成的。我喜欢它。他告诉瑞安，当我们回到办公室时，你最好收拾好你的东西。这现在开始了我也最喜欢的故事情节之一。帕姆终于在她的艺术展上了。她在等人们到来。
And we had a fan question. Alex Lane, Ryan Moberly, and Shelley Jones would like to know what kind of discussions occurred regarding Pam's art show outfit. And here, this little, like, swoopy side ponytail. Pam just is trying to look like she lives, I feel like, in the East Village of New York. Yes, well, they wanted to know if I had any input into what artsy Pam would look like that night. oh yes I did and it was so much fun. Carrie Bennett and I, we had the best time. She came up with this idea of kind of like this beatnik turtle neck with the little jumper over top. And then Kim Ferry and I thought, what is the hairstyle that coordinates with this little hipster outfit? And we thought low side pony. And I think it works. It's not just. just any low side pony though. It's got a little bit of curl. It's kind of relaxed. Yeah. Yeah. It's smoothed out. It's not her like frizzy curly hair that we normally see her with. She is ready to walk out of that art show into 1960 something. It's so sweet. I absolutely loved it. And you can see all of Pam's art behind her. It's a series of watercolors of, you know, simple, ordinary items and things, which I think. kind of goes to that whole theme of the show and Pam finding beauty and ordinary things. And I liked the juxtaposition that, you know, Pam's wall is like a coffee mug and a stapler and a vase holding flowers and, you know, a painting of Dunder Mifflin.
我们有一个粉丝提问。亚历克斯·莱恩、瑞安·莫伯利和雪莉·琼斯想知道关于帕姆艺术展服装进行了什么样的讨论。还有这个，这个像这样的小侧马尾。帕姆只是试图看起来像她住在，我觉得，纽约的东村。是的，好吧，他们想知道我是否对那天晚上的艺术帕姆应该是什么样子有任何建议。哦，是的，我有，而且太有趣了。凯莉·贝内特和我，我们玩得很开心。她想出了这个主意，有点像这种垮掉派的高领毛衣，外面套着小背心。然后金·费里和我想，什么发型能与这套小嬉皮服装相配？我们想到了低侧马尾。而且我认为它很合适。不过不仅仅是任何低侧马尾。它有一点卷度。它有点放松。是的。是的。它被抚平了。不是我们通常看到的她那种毛躁的卷发。她准备好走出那个艺术展，进入1960年代的某个时候了。太甜了。我绝对喜欢它。你可以看到帕姆身后所有的艺术作品。这是一系列水彩画，你知道，简单的、普通的物品和东西，我认为这有点符合节目的整个主题，帕姆在普通事物中发现美。而且我喜欢这种并置，你知道，帕姆的墙上是咖啡杯、订书机、插花的花瓶，你知道，还有一幅邓德·米夫林的画。
And then just to the left, whoever's art display that was is like aliens or like an alien robot. I'm not really sure what it is. Well, we had a fan question from Molly Warner who says, According to Dunderpedia, Joss Whedon was not satisfied with the original art that was produced for Pam at the art show and that new art had to be made. Can you clarify what that original art was and why it had to be changed? Well, we asked Brent about this, and here's what he told us. What I remember most about Joss Whedon's directing of this episode was a crisis that happened around one of the watercolor drawings that appears in Pam's art show.
然后就在左边，不管那是谁的艺术展示，是外星人或者像外星机器人。我不太确定那是什么。好吧，我们有一个来自莫莉·华纳的粉丝提问，她说，根据邓德百科（Dunderpedia），乔斯·韦登对为帕姆艺术展制作的原始艺术品不满意，必须制作新的艺术品。你能澄清一下那原始艺术品是什么，以及为什么要更换它吗？好吧，我们问了布伦特这个问题，这就是他告诉我们的。关于乔斯·韦登执导这一集，我记忆最深的是帕姆艺术展中出现的一幅水彩画引发的危机。
Now, these watercolor drawings were created by the art department at the office, and they appear in the background of all of the shots of Jenna. And, you know, as background items, they might not seem that important. But when we got on set, there was one drawing that Joss just strongly felt that Pam's character would not have done. It was a watercolor drawing of a church. and he just felt it was out of character for her. And you have to imagine when you're shooting a television episode,
现在，这些水彩画是由办公室的美术部门创作的，它们出现在珍娜所有镜头的背景中。而且，你知道，作为背景物品，它们看起来可能没那么重要。但当我们到达片场时，有一幅画乔斯强烈地认为帕姆这个角色不会画。那是一幅教堂的水彩画。他只是觉得这不符合她的性格。你必须想象，当你拍摄电视剧集时，
the time pressure is so intense. You do not have time to stop and mess around. And Joss, however, felt so passionately about this picture that he stopped production and said, I need a new picture. I would like a picture of a stapler. That's what I think that Pam would have drawn. And like I say, the whole production shut down.
时间压力非常大。你没有时间停下来胡闹。然而，乔斯对这幅画感觉非常强烈，以至于他停止了制作并说，我需要一幅新画。我想要一幅订书机的画。这就是我认为帕姆会画的东西。就像我说的那样，整个制作停工了。
They brought the executive producer Greg Daniels to set. they had a big discussion about it, but Joss would not back down. And we were on location. We didn't have the art department with us. Who is going to draw a picture of a stapler? So the assistant director, we were on a location at a university, the assistant director went into a classroom full of art students and said, is anyone here able to draw a watercolor of a stapler? And they pulled some young woman out, and they paid her 50 bucks or something, and she just cranked out this picture of a stapler that you see in the background of all of Pam's shots. And afterwards, I was riding back in the van, you know, to home base with Joss. And I said, Joss, what was all that about?
他们把执行制片人格雷格·丹尼尔斯带到了片场。他们对此进行了激烈的讨论，但乔斯不肯让步。而且我们在外景地。我们没有美术部门和我们在一起。谁会画一幅订书机的画？所以助理导演，我们在大学的外景地，助理导演走进了一个坐满艺术系学生的教室，说，这里有人能画一幅订书机的水彩画吗？他们拉出了一个年轻女子，给了她50块钱左右，她就画出了你在帕姆所有镜头背景中看到的这幅订书机的画。事后，我坐在面包车里，你知道，和乔斯一起回基地。我说，乔斯，那到底是怎么回事？
Why did you get so intense about this? And he said, Brent, in my experience, as a director, every single time that I have felt strongly about some detail of the shoot, and I have allowed myself to be persuaded out of it because of time pressure, 100% of the time, I have intensely regretted making that choice. And so now I understand that I should never compromise when I feel something strongly as a director. It's a great lesson. In my limited experience as a director, I've never forgotten it. I think it's a really good lesson for all of us as artists. Stick to your guns. If you feel it passionately, you're probably right. I have to say, Angela, the watercolor that stood out to me the most when we first flash up to her wall was that stapler. Yeah, me too.
你为什么对这个这么紧张？他说，布伦特，根据我的经验，作为一名导演，每一次我对拍摄的某个细节感觉强烈，而我因为时间压力允许自己被说服放弃它时，100%的情况下，我都对做出那个选择感到非常后悔。所以现在我明白，当我作为导演对某事感觉强烈时，我绝不应该妥协。这是一个很好的教训。在我作为导演的有限经验中，我从未忘记它。我认为这对我们所有艺术家来说都是一个非常好的教训。坚持你的立场。如果你强烈地感觉到它，你很可能是对的。我不得不说，安吉拉，当我们第一次闪到她的墙上时，最让我印象深刻的水彩画就是那个订书机。是的，我也是。
It was absolutely what Pam would have done, because Pam, we already established she's sort of drawing things in her world and she sketched a tape dispenser. It would make sense to me. And then, you know, Jim, I feel like that stapler also represents Jim. Jim put that stapler in Dwight's jello, mold, you know? I never thought of that. Yeah, that's what I thought. I thought Pam painted that stapler because she was thinking of Jim. I just got chills. Well, I got a little lowdown on the Dunder-Mifflin painting from Kentapedia. He said that that is not actually a watercolor, but it was a photograph of our building that they manipulated to look like a watercolor. Oh, like just some fancy kind of graphics. Yeah. So no one ever did a from blank page watercolor of the building. You know,
那绝对是帕姆会做的事情，因为帕姆，我们已经确定她有点在画她世界里的东西，她画了一个胶带分配器。这对我来说很有意义。然后，你知道，吉姆，我觉得那个订书机也代表了吉姆。吉姆把那个订书机放进了德怀特的果冻模具里，你知道吗？我从来没想过这一点。是的，这就是我想的。我想帕姆画那个订书机是因为她在想吉姆。我刚才起鸡皮疙瘩了。好吧，我从肯特百科（Kentapedia）那里得到了关于邓德·米夫林画作的内幕。他说那实际上不是水彩画，而是我们大楼的照片，他们对其进行了处理，使其看起来像水彩画。哦，就像一些花哨的图形处理。是的。所以从来没有人从空白页开始画大楼的水彩画。你知道，
that time, a while back, Jenna invited me to do a wine and canvas night. Yes. And it was so fun. It was like part of a mall, like, but you entered from outside, right? Yeah. It was a mall in Pasadena. Yeah. And we went and you kind of just sort of pick a random night to go.
那次，很久以前，珍娜邀请我参加一个“红酒与画布”之夜。是的。太有趣了。它就像商场的一部分，比如，但你是从外面进去的，对吧？是的。那是帕萨迪纳的一个商场。是的。我们去了，你只是随便选个晚上去。
And I wasn't really sure what we were painting. And then we found out we were painting cats on a fence at nighttime. Yes. And I still have mine. My husband loves it so much. He hung it by where he feeds the cats. So the cats see the cats on the fence as they eat their dinner. It's kind of funny.
我不确定我们在画什么。然后我们发现我们在画夜晚栅栏上的猫。是的。我仍然保留着我的。我丈夫非常喜欢它。他把它挂在他喂猫的地方。所以猫在吃晚餐时能看到栅栏上的猫。这有点好笑。
But I became sort of really interested in this wine and canvas night. We were talking about doing another one, maybe inviting a few friends. I found that they do wine and canvas and everyone can paint the Dunder-Mifflin building. Oh my gosh. That is amazing. Wouldn't you want to do that? I would love to do that. Angela, I think it would be really weird if you and I showed up at a wine and canvas
但我对这个“红酒与画布”之夜变得非常感兴趣。我们当时在谈论再参加一次，也许邀请几个朋友。我发现他们做“红酒与画布”，每个人都可以画邓德·米夫林大楼。哦，天哪。那太棒了。你不想那样做吗？我很想那样做。安吉拉，我觉得如果你和我出现在“红酒与画布”
and painted Dunder Mifflin. There's like a room of people. Like you sign up. We showed up there were probably 30 people there. And we each had a little seating assignment. We had our canvas and our paints. And then they pass around wine. And the teacher is at the front.
画邓德·米夫林会很奇怪。就像一个房间里的人。就像你报名参加。我们到那里时可能有30个人。我们每个人都有一个小座位分配。我们有我们的画布和颜料。然后他们分发红酒。老师在前面。
She had a headset on, remember, so we could all hear. So you and I would be in a room with like 30 other people, total strangers. I totally remember it because my daughter has always from the time she was born loved cats. She loves cats, and I knew she was going to love this painting. And I didn't want my son to feel left out when I came home from my painting night. So on my canvas, I added a little spaceship out in the sky because he loved outer space. So I was like, okay, well, this will bring him into this painting. And we have it in our playroom.
她戴着耳机，记得吗，所以我们都能听到。所以你和我会在一个有其他30个人的房间里，完全是陌生人。我完全记得，因为我女儿从出生起就一直喜欢猫。她喜欢猫，我知道她会喜欢这幅画。当我从绘画之夜回家时，我不想让我的儿子感到被冷落。所以在我的画布上，我在天空中加了一个小飞船，因为他喜欢外太空。所以我当时想，好吧，这会把他带进这幅画里。我们把它放在我们的游戏室里。
I love it. up. But I do. I want to do a wine and canvas night and I want to paint Dundermifflin, Jenna. I can't say I want to do that. You don't want to paint Dunder Mifflin? I know. Well, you have it, don't you? You own it. I already have a painting. I was going to leave that for the end. You own it. But also, Jenna, what if your painting was horrible? I hope your attempt at painting Dunder Mifflin. No, I'm kidding. Well, I will say this, too. My daughter's gotten really into watercolor painting.
我喜欢它。但我确实想参加一个“红酒与画布”之夜，我想画邓德·米夫林，珍娜。我不能说我想那样做。你不想画邓德·米夫林？我知道。好吧，你已经有了，不是吗？你拥有它。我已经有一幅画了。我本来想把它留到最后。你拥有它。但还有，珍娜，如果你的画很糟糕怎么办？我希望你尝试画邓德·米夫林。不，我在开玩笑。好吧，我也会说这个。我女儿真的很喜欢水彩画。
And so it's very funny to me that I, as Jenna, am now sitting around every day doing watercolor paintings like my character Pam did. And I think I've gotten really good at doing flowers. I've actually watched some tutorial video. Well, maybe I'll watch a tutorial video on painting Dunder Mifflin and I'll... There must be one. I'll paint it and show it to you. there you go. Okay, sorry, where are we, lady?
所以对我来说非常有趣的是，作为珍娜，我现在每天坐着做水彩画，就像我的角色帕姆做的那样。而且我认为我在画花方面变得非常擅长。我实际上看过一些教程视频。好吧，也许我会看一个关于画邓德·米夫林的教程视频，我会……一定有一个。我会画出来并给你看。就这样。好吧，抱歉，我们在哪里，女士？
Well, back at Dundra Mifflin, Meredith is still hiding from the bat and everyone is just leaving for the day. Everyone's like, bye. Crete is like, later, Mary Beth. Yes, people wanted to know if that was improvisation, no, that was scripted. Well, there are a few deleted scenes that happen right here, Jenna,
好吧，回到邓德·米夫林，梅雷迪思还在躲避蝙蝠，每个人都要下班了。每个人都说，再见。克里德说，回头见，玛丽·贝丝。是的，人们想知道那是否是即兴发挥，不，那是剧本写的。好吧，这里有几个删除的场景，珍娜，
that are worth mentioning. One is that there's a few cutaways that they didn't have time for of Meredith trying to leave the bathroom and then seeing the bat screaming and going back in. Oh, okay. You know, so kind of playing up the fact
值得一提。一个是，他们没有时间放几个切入镜头，是梅雷迪思试图离开洗手间，然后看到蝙蝠尖叫着跑回去。哦，好吧。你知道，所以有点强调了
that she really does feel trapped and she really is scared. And then there's a scene of Dwight looking through the blinds and screaming at her. So there's this sort of like buildup of this moment. And then the other scene that I love
她确实感到被困住了，而且她确实很害怕。然后有一个德怀特透过百叶窗看她并对她尖叫的场景。所以这个时刻有一种积累。然后我喜欢的另一个场景
that's deleted is as everyone's leaving for the day, leaving Meredith trapped, Angela and Kelly exit together. And Angela says, says, just goes to show you the power of prayer. And Kelly says, you prayed for this? And Angela says, in a general sense. Oh, my goodness. So did I pray that Meredith need some kind of reckoning? And it's going to happen. Wow. I know. I guess Angela maybe prayed that she would be scared into better behavior. Yes. And this is, she feels the answer to her prayer. Better lifestyle choices, Meredith. So now we have the scene, the scene of Dwight going in to capture this bat. And it ends up landing on Meredith's head.
被删掉的是，当每个人都下班离开，把梅雷迪思困在里面时，安吉拉和凯莉一起离开。安吉拉说，这正好向你展示了祈祷的力量。凯莉说，你为这个祈祷了？安吉拉说，从广义上讲。哦，天哪。所以我祈祷梅雷迪思需要某种报应？而且它会发生。哇。我知道。我想安吉拉可能祈祷她会被吓到从而表现得更好。是的。这就是，她觉得这是她祈祷的答案。更好的生活方式选择，梅雷迪思。所以现在我们有了德怀特进去捕捉这只蝙蝠的场景。它最终落在了梅雷迪思的头上。
So he has to put a trash bag over her head with the bat inside. And kind of like wrestle her around. Insanity. Well, you know we got a lot of mail about this one, Angela. Monica Sweeney, Jessica Bone, Ashley McGetrick, Aaron Westra, and Raphael Bressel Smith, and, I mean, just countless others, said, the scene with Dwight trapping the bat on Meredith's head looked so real. How did they do it?
所以他不得不把一个垃圾袋套在她的头上，蝙蝠在里面。有点像和她扭打在一起。疯狂。好吧，你知道我们收到了很多关于这个的邮件，安吉拉。莫妮卡·斯威尼、杰西卡·伯恩、阿什利·麦克格特里克、亚伦·韦斯特拉和拉斐尔·布雷塞尔·史密斯，我是说，还有无数其他人，说，德怀特把蝙蝠困在梅雷迪思头上的场景看起来太真实了。他们是怎么做到的？
Well, we asked Kate to tell us all about the scene, and she told us she worked with both a real bat and a mechanical bat. Here's what else she had to say. Yes, we had a real bat with like five handlers. I wish I had five cameras Yes but we were not letting any noise around The bat you couldn't I couldn't scream
好吧，我们请凯特告诉我们关于这个场景的一切，她告诉我们她和一只真蝙蝠以及一只机械蝙蝠一起工作。这就是她要说的其他内容。是的，我们有一只真蝙蝠，有五个驯兽师。我希望我有五个摄像机。是的，但我们没有让蝙蝠周围有任何噪音。你不能，我不能尖叫
So even though I was screaming I was acting like I was screaming When I was shooting because don't upset the bat Something about the sonar And then we had this motorized thing that I had of my head We actually did have a stunt double But she I don't really think they used her And maybe one little shot with her in it one cutaway
所以即使我在尖叫，我在拍摄时也表现得像我在尖叫。因为不要打扰蝙蝠。关于声纳的一些事情。然后我头上有一个电动的东西。我们确实有一个特技替身。但她，我真的不认为他们用了她。也许有一个小镜头有她在里面，一个切入镜头
but I did all of it the motorized thing on the head it was like sort of like this fluttery thing was almost like a headband with a motor and then there was a human being with a
但我做了所有的事情。头上的电动东西，它有点像这种飘动的东西，几乎像一个带马达的发带，然后有一个人带着一个
like a puppety thing with a stick he was on his knees and he was trying to put the stick up my skirt before he introduced himself which whatever I mean a little out of order and yes
像木偶一样的东西，带着一根棍子，他跪着，他试图在介绍自己之前把棍子伸进我的裙子里，这不管怎么说，我是说有点顺序不对，而且是的
I could breathe with a bag over my head. We figured it out. It was fine. So I was acting my app. And it was one of the most fun scenes I got to do with Rain because he is an amazing actor and he goes for it, man. So but I'm not afraid. I have never been afraid of Rayne Wilson or Dwight Trute. So that is, that's it. Same bad time. Same bad channel. I don't want you to say that for us. Yeah. I guess Phil Shea got this mechanical back. like a battery operated Halloween toy and they put it on a headband on her head because it really does look like there are wings flapping inside that bag. It was what a good, just old fashioned
我可以在头上套着袋子呼吸。我们解决了。没问题。所以我是在表演我的戏。这是我和雷恩一起拍的最有趣的场景之一，因为他是一个了不起的演员，他全力以赴，伙计。所以，但我并不害怕。我从来没有害怕过雷恩·威尔逊或德怀特·舒特。所以就是这样。同样的蝙蝠时间。同样的蝙蝠频道。我不想让你为我们说那个。是的。我想菲尔·谢伊得到了这个机械蝙蝠。像一个电池驱动的万圣节玩具，他们把它放在她头上的发带上，因为它看起来确实像袋子里有翅膀在扇动。这是一个多么好的、老派的
movie magic moment. Yeah. It was like some new technology and old tech all came together. Yes. I have a memory, Jenna, of like Kim Ferry and Phil Shea working on that headband. Like he, I remember it in her hair and makeup area. Do you? Like, she was, like, sort of, like, flossing with it and stuff. She had it on one of those little mannequins. Yeah.
电影魔术时刻。是的。这就像一些新技术和旧技术结合在一起。是的。我有一个记忆，珍娜，金·费里和菲尔·谢伊在制作那个发带。就像他，我记得在她的发型和化妆区。你记得吗？她，就像，在用它做牙线之类的。她把它放在那些小人体模型之一上。是的。
And he was in there with the little battery operated controls explaining how it would work, and they would put a bag over it, and they would test it. I remember that, too. We must have been in there in the trailer when they were doing that. I have that same memory. Oh, man. And then on top of it, there was a guy with a stick and a puppet. My God.
他在那里用电池驱动的控制器解释它是如何工作的，他们会把袋子套在上面，然后他们会测试它。我也记得那个。我们一定是在他们做那个的时候在拖车里。我有同样的记忆。哦，天哪。而且最重要的是，有一个人拿着棍子和木偶。天哪。
What was that about? No, I know. I mean, Kate said, like, he had to put a stick up her skirt. Like, maybe they had all these different ways the bat might be under the bag. Anyway, well done, everyone. It was a team effort. But I thought that scene was fantastic. Well, the other thing she said in her clip, too, Angela, was about how she wasn't allowed to actually scream.
那是怎么回事？不，我知道。我是说，凯特说，他不得不把棍子伸进她的裙子里。我是说，也许他们有所有这些不同的方式，蝙蝠可能在袋子下面。无论如何，做得好，大家。这是一个团队努力。但我认为那个场景太棒了。好吧，她在片段中说的另一件事，珍娜，是关于她不被允许真正尖叫。
Yes. So when I heard that, I remembered that from our big group scene with the bat. Yes, I did too. When Rain sort of, like, pokes the ceiling up, the real bat is up. there. That shot was the real bat. And we all had to be silent. And I remember we had to be super silent as they brought the bat in and placed the bat. And then when they removed the bat before we started doing all of our screaming and reacting to nothing. Yeah. That happens a lot with animals. I worked with a squirrel where you had to be super quiet around the squirrel. Really?
是的。所以当我听到那个时，我记起了我们和蝙蝠的大型集体场景。是的，我也记得。当雷恩有点，像，把天花板捅上去时，真正的蝙蝠在上面。那个镜头是真正的蝙蝠。我们都必须保持沉默。我记得当他们把蝙蝠带进来并放置蝙蝠时，我们必须超级安静。然后当他们在我们开始做所有尖叫和对虚空做出反应之前移走蝙蝠时。是的。这在动物身上经常发生。我和一只松鼠一起工作，你必须在松鼠周围超级安静。真的吗？
Yeah. No sudden movements around the squirrel. Okay. So now we're back at Pam's art show and Roy has come and he's brought his brother, yes. And, um, and, you know, Roy has just regressed, right? He says all of this stuff that is so insulting. He's like, oh, hey, look at this. Like no one else showed up, but I came and I brought someone. That's pretty cool. Well, you know, I don't know if it's Roy regressing or is he,
是的。松鼠周围没有突然的动作。好吧。所以现在我们回到帕姆的艺术展，罗伊来了，他带了他的兄弟，是的。而且，嗯，而且，你知道，罗伊只是退步了，对吧？他说所有这些话都太侮辱人了。他说，哦，嘿，看这个。就像没有其他人出现，但我来了，而且我带了人。那很酷。好吧，你知道，我不知道是罗伊退步了，还是他
just trying in his very lame attempt here to say, Pam, look, you know, I show up for you. I know, but like, what is he needs a big congratulations for showing up to his girlfriend's art show? Like, you're doing the bare minimum. Roy at his real true self is going to make the most basic amount of effort and expect that to be enough and even applauded. Roy is the type of man who needs to be thanked profusely for doing everyday chores like the dishes and taking out the trash as if he's done something extraordinary. But really, you're just contributing to the partnership of running a household. Yeah. I changed a light bulb.
他在这里试图用一种非常蹩脚的方式说，帕姆，你看，你知道的，我为你付出了。我知道，但是，他来参加女朋友的艺术展难道就需要大加赞赏吗？你只是做了最起码的事情。罗伊在展现他真实自我时，只会付出最基本的努力，并期望这已经足够，甚至还想得到赞美。罗伊就是那种做点洗碗、倒垃圾之类的日常家务，就好像做了什么了不起的大事一样，需要别人大加感谢的男人。但实际上，你只是在为共同经营家庭尽一份力而已。是啊。我换了个灯泡。
Yeah. Oh, my gosh. Thank you. Meanwhile, Roy is not probably thanking Pam for everything she's doing to contribute to running the household. That's the dynamic that Pam has to look forward to if she follows through on this. Well, I definitely think this art show night, she's raw, she's feeling vulnerable, and she needs Roy to be more of a support and he's just not able. And I think that's the reality. Roy is going to be a great partner to someone else that doesn't need the same things from him that Pam needs.
是啊。天哪。谢谢你。与此同时，罗伊可能并没有感谢帕姆为经营家庭所做的一切。如果帕姆真的和罗伊继续走下去，这就是她未来要面对的相处模式。嗯，我绝对认为在艺术展这个晚上，她内心很脆弱，她感到不安，她需要罗伊给予更多的支持，但他就是做不到。我认为这就是现实。罗伊会成为别人的好伴侣，只要那个人对他的需求和帕姆不同。
Well, as he's leaving, he tells her this famous line, which is that her art is the prettiest art of all. the art. Thank you, Roy, for that nugget. So I do have a little post-it and I wrote on it, I'm sorry, is this some Gil sass? Yes, some Gil sass. Yes, because Oscar and Gil show up to the art show. They don't know that Pam has walked up behind them. And Gil is really kind of going off on your art. He's like, listen, real art takes courage and honesty and this is motel art. And Oscar says Those aren't Pam's strong points. I think all of that hits her so harsh. I think it's even more powerful for Pam to hear because in this moment, she's forced to hold up a mirror to her life.
在他离开时，他说了那句名言，说她的艺术是所有艺术中最漂亮的。艺术。谢谢你，罗伊，真是金玉良言。我确实有个小便利贴，我在上面写了，抱歉，这是吉尔的刻薄话吗？是的，是吉尔的刻薄话。是的，因为奥斯卡和吉尔出现在艺术展上。他们不知道帕姆就在他们身后。吉尔真的在对你的艺术评头论足。他说，听着，真正的艺术需要勇气和诚实，而这是汽车旅馆的装饰画。奥斯卡说，这些不是帕姆的长处。我认为所有这些对她来说都太刺耳了。我认为这对帕姆来说更有冲击力，因为在这一刻，她被迫审视自己的生活。
And part of that courage and honesty is finally boldly saying, Roy is not my person. Well, Angela, earlier in this episode, Pam. declares that being back with Roy shows maturity and dignity, remember? And she's like, oh, I hope that didn't sound braggy. But when she hears this from Gill and Oscar, she's being confronted with the fact that getting back with Roy does not show dignity or honesty or courage. Yeah. And I feel like it's one of these beautiful moments on our show where, you know, on the one hand,
而那种勇气和诚实的一部分，就是最终大胆地说出，罗伊不是我的真命天子。嗯，安吉拉，在这集早些时候，帕姆宣称和罗伊复合展现了成熟和尊严，记得吗？她说，哦，我希望这听起来不像是在炫耀。但当她从吉尔和奥斯卡那里听到这些时，她不得不面对这样一个事实：和罗伊复合并不代表尊严、诚实或勇气。是啊。我觉得这是我们剧中非常美妙的时刻之一，你知道，一方面，
we're talking about her art, but on the other hand, for Pam, it's like this self-realization about her choices in her life. Well, you kind of think that it can't get lower for Pam because her only two visitors have been Roy and his brother and Oscar and Gill. And then she's standing there alone. The evening is winding down. She starts to take her art off the wall, But then Michael walks in and we hear Pam Casso and you're like, oh no, oh no, is this going to be good or bad? He's started off with Pam Casso. Yeah, it's like, wow. And I think that's Pam's reaction. Pam's like, oh, Michael, you came. But it's kind of like, I don't even know if I can do this. But Michael is immediately just so taken with her art. And some of this is because of what he's been through today. You know, Michael doesn't know what Pam's been through and Pam doesn't know what Michael's been through. But in this moment, these two human beings are coming together and they heal one another.
我们在谈论她的艺术，但另一方面，对帕姆来说，这是关于她人生选择的自我觉醒。嗯，你可能会觉得帕姆的情况已经跌入谷底了，因为她仅有的两个访客是罗伊和他哥哥，还有奥斯卡和吉尔。然后她独自站在那里。夜晚即将结束。她开始把墙上的画取下来，但这时迈克尔走了进来，我们听到了“帕姆·毕加索”，你会想，哦不，哦不，这到底是好事还是坏事？他以“帕姆·毕加索”开头。是啊，就像是，哇。我想这就是帕姆的反应。帕姆心想，哦，迈克尔，你来了。但感觉就像是，我甚至不知道我能不能应付这个。但迈克尔立刻就被她的艺术深深吸引了。这其中一部分是因为他今天经历的事情。你知道，迈克尔不知道帕姆经历了什么，帕姆也不知道迈克尔经历了什么。但在这一刻，这两个人走到了一起，他们治愈了彼此。
Yeah. Yeah, they're coming together a little hurt and broken from the day. And this is such a beautiful scene, Jenna. I just love all the beats of it. I love how excited Michael is. I love how moved Pam is by his excitement, and he sees that her car and his car, she painted both of them. And it's just such a sweet scene. We had a lot of people write in, Mary Ruff, Soraya Garlip, Madison Schnurple, Stacey Dull, and Layla Baroka, all asked,
是啊。是啊，他们带着这一天的伤痛和破碎走到了一起。这是一个如此美丽的场景，珍娜。我喜欢其中的每一个节奏。我喜欢迈克尔有多兴奋。我喜欢帕姆被他的兴奋所打动，他看到了她的车和他的车，她画了这两辆车。这真是一个甜蜜的场景。我们收到了很多人的来信，玛丽·拉夫、索拉亚·加利普、麦迪逊·施努普尔、斯泰西·达尔和莱拉·巴罗卡，她们都问，
Jenna, how did you prepare for the level of emotion you had to play in this scene when Michael shows up and tells Pam that he's proud of her? did you stay in that emotion during the breaks and if not was it hard to get back between takes guys i will tell you i didn't have to prepare much for this because my steen partner was steve korel and the relationship that i had with steve in real life and i think angela this is a little bit for you too he was someone i looked at up to in the way that you look up to a mentor or a parent and I admired him so much. So just to have him look at me and say, I'm proud of you, I just started crying. Yeah.
珍娜，你是如何为这个场景中需要表现出的情感水平做准备的？当迈克尔出现并告诉帕姆他为她感到骄傲时，你在休息期间一直保持那种情绪吗？如果不是，在拍摄间隙回到那种状态难吗？伙计们，我告诉你们，我不需要为这个做太多准备，因为我的搭档是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔，我和史蒂夫在现实生活中的关系，我想安吉拉，这对你来说也有一点，他是我仰望的人，就像你仰望导师或父母一样，我非常钦佩他。所以只要他看着我说，我为你感到骄傲，我就开始哭了。是啊。
His sincerity and his truth in saying it, he's a wonderful actor and it was easy. Easy. He's just such a special person. So to have moments like that with him, the emotion is pretty ready to go. I did this appearance on Busy Phillips talk show. On Busy Tonight. I remember. Yeah. And it was, it was like around my birthday. And she had secretly called people from the office to send in gifts for me. And you sent in a shirt with a loaf of bread on it. Here's the crazy thing. She reached out to me. She was like, Angie, I want to do this. What do you think? I said, I am literally online buying her a t-shirt with a loaf of bread on it.
他说话时的真诚和真实，他是一位出色的演员，这很容易。很容易。他就是这样一个特别的人。所以能和他有那样的时刻，情绪很容易就到位了。我曾参加过比西·菲利普斯的脱口秀节目。在《比西今夜秀》上。我记得。是啊。那是在我生日左右。她偷偷打电话给《办公室》的人，让他们给我寄礼物。你寄来了一件印有面包的衬衫。最疯狂的是，她联系我时说，安吉，我想做这件事。你觉得怎么样？我说，我正在网上给她买一件印着面包的T恤。
And she was like, oh, my God. Can we have that? So it was this total surprise. And I get all these presents and this whole time that I've been doing this talk show appearance, the entire time, there has been a giant box sitting on the set for like 20 minutes, right? 20 minutes. Easily. And at the end of the segment, she says, well, we have one last gift for you.
她说，哦，天哪。我们可以用那个吗？所以这是一个完全的惊喜。我收到了所有这些礼物，在我参加这个脱口秀节目的整个过程中，有一个巨大的盒子在片场放了大约20分钟，对吧？20分钟。轻松超过。在节目快结束时，她说，好吧，我们还有最后一份礼物给你。
And it's this giant box. And the box pops open and Steve Correll pops out of the box. First of all, I was so scared because I wasn't expecting a human being to come out of the box. And then as soon as I saw that it was Steve, I just like immediately burst into tears. He had sat in a box for like 20 minutes while I droned on giving this. interview just to surprise me for my birthday. I don't know. It's like that's Steve, you guys. It was such a just generous, like, kind, loving things to do. So you just have to, that's how he's always been. So in this moment, shooting the scene with him or any emotional scene with him,
那是一个巨大的盒子。盒子弹开了，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔从盒子里跳了出来。首先，我被吓坏了，因为我没想到盒子里会钻出一个人来。然后当我看到是史蒂夫时，我立刻泪流满面。他在盒子里坐了大约20分钟，而我一直在喋喋不休地接受采访，只是为了给我一个生日惊喜。我不知道。这就是史蒂夫，伙计们。这真是太慷慨、太善良、太有爱心的举动了。所以你只需要，他一直都是这样。所以在那一刻，和他拍摄那个场景，或者和他拍摄任何情感场景时，
it's all just right there. I love that so much, Jenna. I hope people can still watch that because that moment is so sweet and you start to cry and Steve is smiling and you guys hug and you say, how long have you been in there? And he's like, for a while because they had to set that box before you came out. Yes. So he was there before the interview and through the whole interview. Yes. Well, we asked Brent about the art show and how they created this moment between Michael and Pam. And Jenna, you might want to buckle in because get ready for a love fest from Brent Forrester. When people ask me, what is my favorite episode of TV that I have ever written? I always say business school. And partly it's because the episode is so nicely designed. It's got that big
一切都自然而然地流露出来。我太喜欢那个了，珍娜。我希望人们还能看到那个片段，因为那一刻太甜了，你开始哭，史蒂夫在笑，你们拥抱在一起，你说，你在里面待了多久？他说，待了一会儿，因为他们必须在你出来之前把盒子放好。是的。所以他在采访前就在那里了，并且贯穿了整个采访。是的。嗯，我们问了布伦特关于艺术展以及他们是如何创造迈克尔和帕姆之间这一时刻的。而且珍娜，你可能要坐稳了，因为准备好迎接布伦特·福雷斯特的赞美狂潮吧。当人们问我，我写过的最喜欢的电视剧集是什么？我总是说《商学院》。部分原因是这一集设计得太好了。它有一个关于蝙蝠和吸血鬼的精彩
comedy C story with the bat and the vampire. It's got a big comedy performance story with Michael going to business school. But above all, it has this tremendous emotional story with Pam's art show. I think that what is happening in Pam's art show is one of those wonderful coincidences of the experience of the writer, me, and the actress, Jenna, coming together. If you try to be an artist of any kind, a writer, an actress, any artist at all, you have to believe in yourself so profoundly. And inevitably, there will come moments of failure where you're believing. leaf in yourself is dashed. And it is so painful and unforgettable when it happens to a human being. And I think it's really what Jenna is expressing at the end of this episode. If you read
喜剧C故事。它有一个关于迈克尔去商学院的精彩喜剧表演故事。但最重要的是，它有一个关于帕姆艺术展的巨大情感故事。我认为帕姆艺术展中发生的事情是编剧（我）和演员（珍娜）的经验之间美妙的巧合之一。如果你试图成为任何形式的艺术家，作家、演员，任何艺术家，你都必须深刻地相信自己。不可避免地，会有失败的时刻，你对自己的信念会破灭。当这种事发生在一个人的身上时，它是如此痛苦且令人难忘。我认为这正是珍娜在这一集结尾所表达的。如果你读过
her tremendous book, an actor's life, which is both an instructional manual and a riveting autobiography, you will learn that Jenna Fisher spent seven years trying to break into the business of acting. At the end of seven years, she felt that she had failed, she packed up her car, and she decided she was going to return home to Missouri. She was only persuaded to stay by her acting coach and her manager who said, please, Jenna, spend one more season trying out for TV, and that's when she got the office. But that experience of terrible defeat is something that I believe she never forgot,
她那本了不起的书《演员的生活》，它既是一本指导手册，也是一部引人入胜的自传，你会了解到珍娜·费舍尔花了七年时间试图闯入演艺圈。七年后，她觉得自己失败了，她收拾好车，决定回到密苏里州的老家。她只是被她的表演教练和经纪人说服留下来，他们说，求你了，珍娜，再试一个演出季的电视试镜，就在那时她得到了《办公室》。但那种可怕的失败经历是我相信她永远不会忘记的，
and it's what she's expressing at the end of this episode. Steve Corell says that when he watches business school, that moment where Michael Scott hugs Pam and there's a close on her face, Steve says he can see five different emotions play through Jenna's face in that performance. It is heartbreak and it is gratitude. It is just the whole human experience wrapped up in a single take. It's a tremendous performance and it's part of why I will always be so grateful that I got to write this episode for one of my favorite actresses of all time, Jenna Fisher. Oh my gosh, Brent.
这正是她在这一集结尾所表达的。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔说，当他看《商学院》时，迈克尔·斯科特拥抱帕姆的那一刻，镜头特写在她的脸上，史蒂夫说他能看到珍娜在表演中展现出的五种不同的情绪。那是心碎，也是感激。这只是包裹在一个镜头里的完整人类体验。这是一场了不起的表演，这也是为什么我永远会如此感激能为我最喜欢的演员之一珍娜·费舍尔写这一集的原因。天哪，布伦特。
What are you going to say after that? That is the most beautiful thing ever. Like, Jenna, that is so lovely. You know what? I am going to save that and I'm going to listen to that anytime I am having a bad day because that really, thank you. That lifts me up. Jenna, I have been at all of your big life moments. Really, I have.
在那之后你还能说什么？那是史上最美妙的事情。珍娜，这太可爱了。你知道吗？我要把它保存下来，每当我心情不好时我都会听，因为这真的，谢谢你。这让我振作起来。珍娜，我见证了你人生中所有的重要时刻。真的，我见证过。
I have heard toast and speeches about you and that's probably the best. I was at your wedding. Brent should have given a toast at your wedding. Clearly. Clearly. Oh, my gosh. He like recapped your book and your whole life experience. And then what Steve said was so beautiful.
我听过关于你的祝酒词和演讲，那可能是最好的。我参加了你的婚礼。布伦特本应该在你的婚礼上致祝酒词的。显然。显然。天哪。他回顾了你的书和你整个人生经历。然后史蒂夫说的话太美了。
I mean, Jenna, Brent was going on for so long. He ran out of air. Did you hear at the end? He had to go, he was so passionate talking about you. Everything he said is true. There's one thing. I never actually packed up my car and said I was going to leave. but I did say I called my managers after seven years of failures and said, I've decided to become a vet technician.
我是说，珍娜，布伦特说了太久了。他都喘不过气来了。你听到了吗？最后他不得不停下来，他谈论你时太投入了。他说的每一件事都是真的。有一件事。我从未真正收拾好车说我要离开。但我确实说过，在经历了七年的失败后，我给我的经纪人打了电话，说，我决定去当兽医助理。
I had signed up. It was a two-year program. I'd been doing some animal rescue, and I was going to do it full time. And I wanted my vet tech license so that I could administer medicines. And so I was like, I'm out of here. And it is true that my manager and my acting coach sort of yelled at me. And they were like, what did you think an acting career was? You thought it was just a bunch of ups, just a bunch of successes?
我已经报名了。那是一个两年的项目。我一直在做一些动物救援工作，我打算全职做这个。我想要我的兽医助理执照，这样我就可以给药了。所以我当时想，我要离开这里了。我的经纪人和表演教练确实对我大吼大叫。他们说，你以为演艺生涯是什么？你以为它只是一连串的上升，一连串的成功吗？
No, it's little successes followed by many failures. This is what being an actor is. And it's true what Brent says too, which is that I did channel a lot of those struggling years into my performance for Pam. I literally sat at a reception desk and dreamed of being an artist. I have done that. I did it for seven years. So I deeply, deeply felt Pam's longing.
不，它是小小的成功伴随着许多失败。这就是做演员的意义。布伦特说的也是对的，那就是我确实把很多那些挣扎的岁月融入到了帕姆的表演中。我真的坐在前台，梦想着成为一名艺术家。我做过。我做了七年。所以我深深地、深深地感受到了帕姆的渴望。
Yeah. Brent also sent us in an audio clip where he discussed just the overall story for this episode with Pam and Michael and why he thinks that it resonates so much with people. And here's what he had to say about that. I remember before I was sent off to write this episode, I got into a big debate with Greg Daniels, the show creator, about the story of Pam's art show. and I at the time thought of myself as a sophisticated storyteller, and I took the position that this story did not work. Because, I said to Greg, a story is about a protagonist, pursuing a goal, overcoming obstacles,
是啊。布伦特还给我们发来了一段音频片段，他在其中讨论了这一集关于帕姆和迈克尔的整体故事，以及为什么他认为它能引起人们如此强烈的共鸣。以下是他对此的看法。我记得在我被派去写这一集之前，我和剧集主创格雷格·丹尼尔斯就帕姆艺术展的故事进行了一场激烈的辩论。当时我自认为是一个老练的讲故事的人，我坚持认为这个故事行不通。因为，我对格雷格说，一个故事是关于主角追求目标、克服障碍，
and in the end, accomplishing that goal. And in this case, Pam's goal is to be respected as an artist. But when Michael Scott buys her painting at the end, it doesn't resolve her problem because she does not respect Michael Scott's taste. I'm so facto, her problem is not resolved, and the story does not work. And I remember Greg saying to me, Brent, this is a sophisticated story with a sophisticated ending. It would be like this.
最后实现那个目标。在这种情况下，帕姆的目标是作为一名艺术家受到尊重。但当迈克尔·斯科特在最后买下她的画时，并没有解决她的问题，因为她并不尊重迈克尔·斯科特的品味。因此，她的问题没有解决，故事行不通。我记得格雷格对我说，布伦特，这是一个老练的故事，有一个老练的结局。它会是这样的。
Suppose you, Brent, were the protagonist and your goal was to impress me with your storytelling abilities. But you said something so stupid in the breaking of this story that I fired you and sent you home. You went home, miserable, not having accomplished your goal, but your family dog came up to you, cuddled with you on the couch, and put its head on your lap. This would be an emotional resolution and consolation, even though. your stated goal was not achieved. Greg was so right about this, and it was so funny the way he put it. You know, Greg, his body of work is characterized by these sophisticated endings, where the character does not get what they think they want, but still gets what they
假设你，布伦特，是主角，你的目标是用你的讲故事能力给我留下深刻印象。但你在构思这个故事时说了些愚蠢的话，导致我解雇了你并把你送回家。你回到家，痛苦不堪，没有实现你的目标，但你家的狗走到你身边，在沙发上依偎着你，把头放在你的膝盖上。这会是一种情感上的慰藉和补偿，尽管你的既定目标没有实现。格雷格说得太对了，他表达的方式太有趣了。你知道，格雷格，他的作品特点就是这些老练的结局，角色没有得到他们认为自己想要的东西，但仍然得到了他们
emotionally need at the end. And it's part of the reason why I'm so grateful to have worked on this show and worked with Greg Daniels, who taught me so many priceless lessons about storytelling. Ugh, Jenna, we both feel like we know Greg. We've known him a long time. But when I hear these stories from the writer's room, it's this whole new perspective on Greg. And man, I am just more and more impressed with him in how he can convey a thought or explain the dynamics between human relationships. And he's so flippin smart. It's so true. And it is such a sophisticated way to tell a story. I mean, they've written songs about that idea. You don't get what you want, but you get what you need. Yeah. And that is what happens in this story. Yeah. It's so layered.
情感上需要的东西。这就是我为什么如此感激能参与这部剧并与格雷格·丹尼尔斯共事的原因，他教会了我许多关于讲故事的无价之课。呃，珍娜，我们都觉得我们认识格雷格。我们认识他很久了。但当我听到编剧室里的这些故事时，这是对格雷格的一个全新的视角。天哪，我对他如何传达思想或解释人际关系之间的动态越来越印象深刻。他太聪明了。这太真实了。这是一种非常老练的讲故事方式。我的意思是，他们写过关于那个想法的歌。你没有得到你想要的，但你得到了你需要的。是啊。这就是这个故事中发生的事情。是啊。它太有层次了。
Pam and Michael heal one another and give one another what they need. Yeah. Someone to say, I'm proud of you and someone to show Michael, I guess, what the power of a piece of paper is. That's what he says. It's so sweet. Well, and also just to be appreciated, Pam really appreciated that he came there. And it's a reminder for Michael that, you know, business is people and you can't cancel people. That's right.
帕姆和迈克尔治愈了彼此，并给予了对方他们所需要的东西。是啊。有人说，我为你感到骄傲，有人向迈克尔展示，我想，一张纸的力量是什么。他就是这么说的。太甜了。嗯，还有就是被欣赏，帕姆真的很感激他能去那里。这对迈克尔来说是一个提醒，你知道，生意就是人，你不能取消人。没错。
We had a question from Amber, Julie, Aubrey, and Roe hit. Did anyone end up keeping the picture of the office that Pam made? Yep, me. We talked about that in Casino Night with John. Yes. That I got to keep that and I have it hanging down in my entryway of my house. And a little thank you to Phil Shea for making that happen for Jenna. Well, we wrap up this episode, finding out that Ryan has not lost his job, that Michael has just moved him to the annex, which is such a punishment.
我们收到了安布尔、朱莉、奥布里和罗希特的问题。有人最后留下了帕姆画的那幅办公室的画吗？是的，我。我们在约翰参与的《赌场之夜》中谈过那个。是的。我把它留下了，它挂在我家门厅里。还要感谢菲尔·谢伊为珍娜促成了这件事。嗯，我们结束这一集时发现，瑞安并没有丢掉工作，迈克尔只是把他调到了附楼，这真是一种惩罚。
Because now he's going to have to share a desk pod with Kelly. And Kelly is so excited. She's so thrilled. And here's a little tidbit from the DVD commentary. Brent said he went into Mindy's office and he said, Mindy, here's this scene and he pitched the scene to her and she began to just improvise as Kelly
因为现在他必须和凯利共用一个办公桌区。凯利太兴奋了。她太激动了。这是DVD评论中的一个小花絮。布伦特说他走进明迪的办公室，他说，明迪，这是这个场景，他向她推销了这个场景，她开始即兴表演凯利
how Kelly would respond to this news. And Brent just wrote it all down verbatim. Oh, he was like, he said Mindy is so great at channeling Kelly that you literally could go in and pitch to her a Kelly moment and she'd be like, oh, she would totally say this. I love that. Well, we had some fan questions
凯利会如何回应这个消息。布伦特只是逐字逐句地写了下来。哦，他说，明迪在演绎凯利方面太棒了，你真的可以进去向她推销一个凯利的时刻，她会说，哦，她绝对会这么说。我喜欢那个。嗯，我们有一些粉丝问题
about this. Haley, Fortino, Jillian, Audrey, and Mariel all asked, was Michael moving Ryan to the annex as a punishment a way to get Ryan back out of the bullpen so that he wasn't as visible and could be in the writer's room some more? I'm sure. Yes. Yeah. Because now our three writers were all back there, Paul, BJ, and Mindy. No, it was very smart. Well, Jenna, there are some deleted scenes, you know, in this episode that are really fantastic. I haven't talked too much about them, but there are two that are sort of interesting, and I thought I'd share a little bit with you about that. And we had some fan questions. So here's the first one. And Ryan Moberly, Jamie Kearns, Ali Giancarlo, and Jamie Miller all wrote in, and they said, in the deleted scenes, Karen attempts
关于这个。海莉、福蒂诺、吉莉安、奥黛丽和玛丽尔都问，迈克尔把瑞安调到附楼作为惩罚，是不是为了把瑞安从大办公室里调出来，这样他就不会那么显眼，可以更多地待在编剧室里？我肯定。是的。是啊。因为现在我们的三个编剧都在后面，保罗、BJ和明迪。不，这非常聪明。嗯，珍娜，这一集里有一些删减片段，你知道，真的非常棒。我没有谈论太多，但有两个比较有趣，我想和你分享一下。我们收到了一些粉丝问题。所以这是第一个。瑞安·莫伯利、杰米·卡恩斯、阿里·吉安卡洛和杰米·米勒都写信来，他们说，在删减片段中，凯伦试图
to rip down Pam's art show flyer in the kitchen. All right. They say, I know. I know. there are so many people that say that Karen didn't deserve all of this hate because her only crime was not being Pam, but can we please discuss? Yes. So what happens, Angela? Okay, well, Karen is in the kitchen. There's a flyer for Pam's art show, and she looks around and she reaches up to grab it to pull it off the wall. And then I think Oscar walks in and she just quickly just leaves. and we don't really know anything more than that, just little glimpse.
在厨房里撕掉帕姆的艺术展传单。好吧。他们说，我知道。我知道。有很多人说凯伦不应该受到所有这些仇恨，因为她唯一的罪过就是不是帕姆，但我们能讨论一下吗？是的。那么发生了什么，安吉拉？好吧，凯伦在厨房里。墙上有一张帕姆艺术展的传单，她环顾四周，伸手去抓它，想把它从墙上扯下来。然后我想奥斯卡走了进来，她就迅速离开了。我们不知道更多了，只是那一瞥。
But, you know, everyone in the office knew about it. I don't know that she was being that vindictive. Maybe she just wanted to see the details. But you could say maybe she didn't want Jim to see it. Maybe she didn't want Jim to want to go. Maybe she wasn't being vindictive. I mean, she was going to take it off the wall. I think this was a good cut.
但是，你知道，办公室里的每个人都知道这件事。我不知道她是否那么怀恨在心。也许她只是想看看细节。但你可以说也许她不想让吉姆看到。也许她不想让吉姆想去。也许她不是在怀恨在心。我的意思是，她要把传单从墙上取下来。我认为这是一个好的剪辑。
because I don't like this side of Karen. I'm glad that this was cut from her story. Me too, because Karen was already so vilified. She didn't need to lean into it, you know? Yeah, I agree. So I think that was a good scene to have deleted. Now, here's another deleted scene that Kate Flannery and I talked about, and Susan Lewis and Kyle Meeker wrote in and said,
因为我不喜欢凯伦的这一面。我很高兴这一段从她的故事中被删掉了。我也是，因为凯伦已经被妖魔化得够多了。她不需要再那样做了，你知道吗？是啊，我同意。所以我认为这是一个应该被删掉的好场景。现在，这是凯特·弗兰纳里和我谈论的另一个删减场景，苏珊·刘易斯和凯尔·米克写信问，
there's a deleted scene where Meredith is telling Oscar a joke about Pam and Roy. The joke is almost all bleeped out. What was the joke? Oh, no. This is like us doing laundry and betrayal. I know, I know. So I said, Kate, what was that all about? I went and watched the scene and the deleted scene is Angela's in the kitchen and Meredith's in there and she's like, hey, why did Pam leave the wedding with Roy?
有一个删减场景是梅雷迪思在给奥斯卡讲一个关于帕姆和罗伊的笑话。这个笑话几乎全被消音了。那个笑话是什么？哦，不。这就像我们在洗衣服和背叛。我知道，我知道。所以我说，凯特，那到底是怎么回事？我去看那个场景，删减的场景是安吉拉在厨房里，梅雷迪思也在那里，她说，嘿，为什么帕姆和罗伊一起离开了婚礼？
And I'm just like, would you stop it? And I leave the kitchen. I am not going to entertain this. Then Oscar comes out of the bathroom. Meredith goes, hey, Oscar, why did Pam leave the wedding? bedding with Roy. And Oscar's like, Meredith, I'm not going to get into this. I think gossip is like harmful. And then Meredith can't even contain herself. And she starts to tell the rest of her joke. And she kind of does a gesture with her hands by her crotch area. And it just is like, because Roy, bleep, bleep, bleep, bleep, bleep, bleep.
我只是说，你能停下来吗？然后我离开了厨房。我不会理会这个。然后奥斯卡从洗手间出来。梅雷迪思说，嘿，奥斯卡，为什么帕姆和罗伊一起离开了婚礼？奥斯卡说，梅雷迪思，我不会参与这个。我认为八卦是有害的。然后梅雷迪思甚至无法控制自己。她开始讲她笑话的其余部分。她用手在胯部附近做了一个手势。这就像是因为罗伊，哔，哔，哔，哔，哔，哔。
And then Oscar's like, gross. And Meredith cackles and says, I know. And leaves the kitchen. And Kate said that in the script, all it said was Meredith tells an off-colored joke to Oscar. That's it. And it didn't say anything else. Is that true, Jenna? Yes, I checked the script and it says, Meredith has one scripted line. Then the script says, Meredith says Roy, then long bleeped sentence while gesturing in an unusual way ambiguously that could be totally nasty or could be something quite different. Hard to tell,
然后奥斯卡说，恶心。梅雷迪思咯咯笑着说，我知道。然后离开了厨房。凯特说在剧本里，上面只写着梅雷迪思给奥斯卡讲了一个荤段子。就是这样。上面没写别的。是真的吗，珍娜？是的，我查了剧本，上面写着，梅雷迪思有一句剧本台词。然后剧本写着，梅雷迪思说罗伊，然后是一长串被消音的句子，同时以一种不寻常的方式模糊地做手势，这可能非常下流，也可能完全是另一回事。很难说，
really, there's no visible lip flap. And then the script says, Oscar says, that's disgusting. So I said, Kate, do you remember what you said? And she said, no, I don't remember. She said, but, you know, I remember I just wanted to try to shock them. And my dad owned a bar in Philadelphia. And so I just tried to throw out some of those bar jokes I had heard. I love that. I love that. Well, guys, that was business school. Yes. Thank you so much to Brent for sending an audio clips and Kate as well for telling us everything about that bat. Yes. And I also want to tell you guys, Brent is an amazing teacher and he's currently teaching an online class called Writing the TV Comedy Script. It is such a bargain. So if you have like an idea for a TV pilot or a TV show that you've been dying to write, you have to check out this class. You can find it at brentforrester.com. Well, thanks you guys so much for listening. We hope you have a fantastic week. Yeah, we'll see you next week for some cocktails. Ooh. Oh, Jenna. One last question for you. What? Do you know what Pan's art show was called?
真的，没有可见的唇部动作。然后剧本写着，奥斯卡说，那太恶心了。所以我说，凯特，你还记得你说了什么吗？她说，不，我不记得了。她说，但是，你知道，我记得我只是想试着震惊他们。我爸爸在费城开了一家酒吧。所以我只是试着抛出一些我听过的酒吧笑话。我喜欢那个。我喜欢那个。好吧，伙计们，这就是《商学院》。是的。非常感谢布伦特发来音频片段，也感谢凯特告诉我们关于那只蝙蝠的一切。是的。我还想告诉你们，布伦特是一位了不起的老师，他目前正在教授一门名为“编写电视喜剧剧本”的在线课程。这真是太划算了。所以如果你有一个电视试播集或电视节目的想法，你一直渴望写出来，你一定要看看这门课。你可以在brentforrester.com找到它。好吧，非常感谢你们的收听。我们希望你们有一个美妙的一周。是啊，我们下周见，喝点鸡尾酒。噢。哦，珍娜。最后一个问题问你。什么？你知道帕姆的艺术展叫什么吗？
What? Artists for art. Did Roy write that? He did. We'll see you next week, guys. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jirkins, and our audio engineer and associate producer is Molly Nugent. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz.
什么？艺术家的艺术。是罗伊写的吗？是他写的。下周见，伙计们。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯。本集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音频工程师和副制片人是莫莉·纽金特。Odyssey的执行制片人是利亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. Thank you. ...he... ...and... ...you know. ...and... ...the... ...you know. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。谢谢。 ...他... ...和... ...你知道。 ...和... ...那... ...你知道。 这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。